FOR. BEING LATE THERE WAS
TRAFFIC ON THE BAY BRIDGE I
THOUGHT EVERYBODY HAD. LEFT OF
SAN FRANCISCO BUT CLEARLY NOT
MAYBE THERE WAS A MASS EXODUS
FROM TEXAS OVER THE WEEKEND. SO
WE ARE GOING TO GET STARTED
WITH OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE LET ME JUST. READ
SOME. I CAN POINTS ABOUT WHAT
WE ARE IN TERMS OF HOW WE ARE
HANDLING THE MEETING OBVIOUSLY.
AS YOU KNOW WE'RE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
MEETING WE ARE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER- BUT WE ARE ALL
PHYSICALLY DISTANT WELL WE'RE
ALSO GOING TO ASK WHATEVER
PUBLIC. SHOWS UP TODAY TO ALSO.
MAINTAIN THE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
WE WILL ALLOW ONE MINUTE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT WHETHER IT'S IN
PERSON OR ON THE PHONE. AND
EVERYBODY HAS THE ABILITY TO
OBVIOUSLY EXIT. THE HEARING
ROOMS- AFTER THE MAKE THE
COMMENT IF THEY WISH- THIS IS
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
MEMBERS HAVE. COULD MAKE THE
REQUEST TO APPEAR REMOTELY WITH
A NUMBER OF MEMBERS HERE IN THE
CHAMBER WHO ARE HERE
PHYSICALLY- WE WILL ALLOW
MEMBERS IN THE ROOM AND THOSE
NUMBERS ARE VIRTUALLY TO
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSIONS
WALLS. CULINARY THERE WILL BE
NO VOTE IN THE COMMITTEE TODAY.
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC COMMENT WE
ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT
THE END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE- THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
WHICH WILL BE POSTED ON THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
WEBSITE BUT ALSO SHOULD BE. ON
THE ASSEMBLY TV IS
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU HAVE ANY
ISSUES PLEASE CALL THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT. NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE. TWO ZERO
NINE NINE. SO ALL LET ME START
IT JUST ALLOW OUR- SENATE NOT
MINIMUM SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YOUR. YEAH BLOOM.
CAREER CHIU. COOPER FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER. CRISTINA
GARCIA. JONES SAWYER. KILEY
LACKEY WE MATHIS MCCARTY MEDINA
MULLIN. THE SYRIAN. BUT DONALD
PATTERSON. FROM LOS. REYES
THREE OF US RUBIO SMITH STONE
VALLADARES WOOD. THANK YOU- WE
ARE HEARING TO. TWO PACKAGES
TODAY- WE ARE HEARING ARE-
EARLY ACTION BUDGET ITEM WHICH
IS COMPRISED PRIMARILY OF OUR
ECONOMIC STIMULUS PROPOSAL
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO. ANNOUNCED
BE ABLE TO ANNOUNCE THE
ESTIMATES PROPOSAL WHICH IS A
NINE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
TO MOVE POPOSAL. MONEY WHICH
WILL BE GOING TO A SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS IN
TERMS OF VERY IMPORTANT RELIEF
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX CUTS
WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL TAX REBATES. IN THE
FORM OF OUR CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT TO HARD
WORKING LOWER INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE WE ALSO ARE
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT CUTS
RESTORATION TOO MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS THAT WERE CAUGHT
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. THE SECOND PART
OF OUR AGENDA WILL BE
CONSIDERATION OF OUR SCHOOL RE
OPENING BILL S. B. EIGHTY SIX.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THERE'S BEEN
A HUGE AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION
AROUND THIS PARTICULAR BILL I
HAVE TO SAY THAT I WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED BY THE LATE LATE
NIGHT LETTER THAT I RECEIVED
FROM. MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS
SUPERINTENDENT OR SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION THE AGAIN ASKED US
TO QUOTE UNQUOTE DO NO HARM. I
THOUGHT THE LETTER WAS TONE
DEAF IT SHOWED A COMPLETE LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE
PARENTS AND STUDENTS ARE. IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IN JUNE WE
PASSED THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WE
APPROPRIATED AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OF MONEY TO
ELLIE AS DISTRICTS
SUPERINTENDENTS TO GET PREPARED
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING THE
BUDGET INSTRUCTIONS WERE. TO
FOR THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE TO DO IN PERSON
LEARNING. WHEN HE WAS HELLO.
UNFORTUNATE DISTRICTS TO THE
FALL BILLION. IN ONLY USED 11%
OF THE MONEY FOR IN PERSON
LEARNING. THEN AGAIN THEY WANT
US TO DO THE SAME THING THEY
WANT US TO GIVE THE MONEY WITH
NO ACCOUNTABILITY NO GUARANTEES
OF IN PERSON LEARNING THIS YEAR-
I AM NORMALLY A HUGE PROPONENT
OF LOCAL CONTROL BUT THIS YEAR.
LOCAL CONTROL HAS BEEN A
COMPLETE FAILURE. WE HAVE SEEN
THE WHOLE TRUST US MODEL FROM
THE DISTRICTS FELL. FIELD OUR
STUDENTS FILTER FAMILIES ITS
FILTER TEACHERS IT'S FILLED OUR
STAFF. WE ARE AT A STANDSTILL
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHY THE
GOVERNOR THE LEGISLATURE HAS
STEPPED IN. TO WORK ON A
SOLUTION TO RE OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS. WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT HARM DONE BECAUSE
UNLIKE THE LETTER THAT WAS SENT
AND WE SEE SIGNIFICANT HARM
DONE TO OUR STUDENTS. WE'VE HAD
A YEAR OF STUDENTS WHO HAVE HAD
TO STAY AT HOME INCLUDING MY
TWO DAUGHTERS. HAVE HAD TO STAY
HOME DO ALL THEIR LEARNING
ONLINE TO OLDER LEARNING BY
THEMSELVES. REALLY IN SOCIAL
ISOLATION WITHOUT THEIR FRIENDS
WITHOUT THEIR TEACHERS THERE'S
LEARNING LOSS. BECAUSE THERE
HAVE BEEN MENTAL HEALTH COSTS.
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE AS A LEGISLATURE AS A
STATE GOVERNMENT TO GET OUR
SCHOOLS. ARE BACK OPEN. AND YOU
CAN REST ASSURED THAT THERE
WILL BE NO PROGRAM THAT HAS
PASSED WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE SAID FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS WITH NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN THIS YEAR. SO WITH THAT
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH. S.
B. EIGHTY SIX AND WE HAVE FROM
ALL WE HAVE IN THIS LEAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
MR PADDOCK FROM ALL ILLEGAL OR
ILLEGAL TO START WITH THAT
PRESENTATION. IN THE WOULD LIKE
TO DO FOR THE MEMBERS ARE OKAY
WE WILL GO THROUGH ALL THE
BILLS. AND THEN WE WILL ALLOW
ON MEMBER QUESTIONS AFTER ALL
THE BILLS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED
AND MEMBER COMMENTS AFTER. SB
EIGHTY FIVE SORRY I NEED MY
GLASSES. THAT'S BEAUTIFUL THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
THANK YOU MR GOOD MORNING.
WARNING OKAY SO WE'RE STARTING
WITH THE STIMULUS PACKAGE RIGHT.
BECAUSE HE- OKAY I'M THE
MORNING CARE TANK- I STIR FONG
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
COOLEY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AN IMMEDIATE ACTION
BUDGET PACKAGE JUST AS OF THE
CHURCH STATED- HE'S A PROUD AND
THIS PACKAGE RESPONDS TO THE
NEEDS OF MILLIONS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. AND CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC IS NINE POINT SIX
BILLION PACKAGE INCLUDES
IMMEDIATE CAP RELIEF TO AN
ESTIMATED FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO STRUGGLING SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE FORM OF
GRANTS FEE WAIVERS AND TAX
RELIEF ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
FOR CHILDCARE IN PARTICULAR
EXTENDING CARE FOR CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. FUNDS FOR
FOOD BANKS AND DIAPER BANKS
EXPANDED ACCESS TO THE COMPLEX
PROGRAM FOR FAMILIES IN NEED OF
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR OUR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS THAT ARE
QUARANTINING AMONG OTHER
IMPORTANT GOALS I'LL BE
PRESENTING AND SUITE OF BILLS
ALONG AND THEN ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WERE ON THE LINE
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS- NUMBER QUESTIONS SO
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE
THIS IS A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
THAT AMENDS THE CURRENT BUDGET-
IT INCLUDES VARIOUS BUDGET BILL
AMENDMENTS AS HIGHLIGHTED IN
HEARING AGENDA SUCH AS BY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID FOR
QUALIFYING LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ANDERSON WILL
ADD TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EFFORTS TO RE ENGAGE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EITHER LEFT
THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDIES
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC OR TO
RE ENGAGE STUDENTS. AT RISK OF
LEAVING. IT PROVIDES SIX
MILLION SUPPORT REGIONAL.
ASSISTANCE TO. UCCS AND CALL
STUDENTS WHO WE HAVE BEEN MADE
ALL OF. FOR CALFRESH THROUGH-
THE CORONA VIRUS REALLY FILLED
FEDERAL ROAD REPAIRS WE
THOUGHT. AND PROVIDES FULL
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES TO PROCESS THESE
ADDITIONAL CALFRESH
APPLICATIONS. IT PROVIDES NINE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR MILLION TO
ISSUE GRANT PAYMENTS TO
HOUSEHOLDS ENROLLED IN THE
CALVERTS PROGRAM AND RECIPIENT
OF. ASSIST I S. AS HE AND CASH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
IMMIGRANTS OR CAPPY- DEALING
FOR THE SUPPLEMENT GRANTS IS
ACTUALLY TO. LATER UNDER SB
EIGHTY- AND ALSO PROVIDES TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO MILLION TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO CAL WORKS THE
CELTICS PROGRAM BY DISREGARDING
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE- INCOME FROM
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS FOR
TELEWORK. APPLICANTS THIS IS
ALREADY- IS ALREADY A PLASTIC
CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS. IT
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
MILLION FOR FOOD BANKS AND AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE MILLION FOR
DIAPER BANKS FAMILIES FOR IT. I
PROVIDES FOR FOUR MILLION FOR
SUPPORT OF SERVICE FUNDING FOR
UP TO TWENTY COUNTIES TO
PROVIDE WRAP AROUND SERVICES
AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS THAT ARE
EITHER QUARANTINING IN HOME. OR
IN A HOTEL AS PART OF THE
STATE'S CURRENT HOUSING FOR THE
HARVEST PROGRAM. THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE OTHER MAJOR SIGNIFICANT-
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE IN THIS
EASY J. OR THAT. SB EIGHTY
FIVE- MOVING ON TO YOU AB SB
EIGHTY SEVEN. WHICH IS A SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE TRAILER
ABOUT. THIS BILL PROVIDES
IMPORTANT RELIEF TO ASSIST
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE COMPLETE
NINETEEN KINDA MAKE. MY
FORMALLY ESTABLISHING AND
EXPANDING THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS WILL BE NINETEEN
RELIEF PROGRAM WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ALSO
KNOWN AS OPEN. IT PROVIDES A
APPROPRIATE OF POINT ZERO SEVEN
FIVE BILLION TO GO THIS TO
ADMINISTER THIS GRANT PROGRAM-
AND SETS ASIDE FIFTY MILLION OF
THIS AMOUNT FOR NONPROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. THAT
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY COULD BE
NINETEEN. WE MAY NOT SEE SB
EIGHTY EIGHT THIS IS THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS WELL. PROVIDES A
ONE TIME SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
STIMULUS PAYMENT TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS MANY WHO WERE
ALREADY IN DIFFICULT ECONOMIC
POSITIONS PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
AND WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS IN
HARMS BY THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. PAYMENTS UNDER TO
GROUPS ALL TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT HOUSEHOLDS OR COUNTY ITC
HOUSEHOLDS AND ALL TWENTY
TWENTY NINETEEN FILERS WITH
INCOME UNDER SEVENTY FIVE. I
DID FILERS WHO ALSO QUALIFY FOR
THE EITC FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TAX YEAR WILL RECEIVE TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THIS BILL ALSO
PROVIDES A ONE TIME SIX HUNDRED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT GRANT. THE
HOUSEHOLDS WERE ENROLLED IN
CALVERT AND RECIPIENTS OF
EXERCISES HE AND KATHY- I
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THE
ALLOCATIONS AND J. THE LANGUAGE
IS IN SB EIGHTY. GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS GRANTS- WILL BE EXEMPT
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE TAXES
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL ALSO
DELAYED BY ONE WEEK A REPORT BY
FINANCES DEMOGRAPHIC UNIT- AS
WE WILL NOT RECEIVE THE
ASSOCIATED FEDERAL CENSUS
BUREAU ESTIMATES UNTIL. APRIL
THIRTIETH THIS YEAR. MOVING ON
TO SB NINETY TWO WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL CORPORATE NINETEEN
RELIEF TRAILER- THIS BILL
PROVIDES FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO THE ACT OF FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. FOR COUNTY ATC AND
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS OUTREACH
IT ALSO WAIVE THE THIRTY WEEK
OFF PERIOD AND CLARIFIES THE
STATE'S. PARTICIPATION IN THE
FEDERAL STATE EXTENDED DURATION
OR THAT ADD PROGRAM. WHICH
PROVIDE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BENEFITS AFTER REGULAR ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ARE EXHAUSTED. IT ALSO PROVIDES
A FORTY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO THE
CHARACTER GRAHAM BY
DISREGARDING ENDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT INCOME. FROM LGBT
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINATIONS FOR
OUR APPLICANTS I GET THE
SPELLING- THE INCLUSION OF THE
DOLLARS AND- J. I'M AND LASTLY
THE BILL MAKES CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE RECENT
EVICTION MORATORIUM EXTENSION
AND STATE EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM PURSUANT TO
SB NINETY ONE TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THAT. MOVING ON TO SB
NINETY THREE THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. THIS BILL RATIFIES
AN ADDENDUM THAT WAS REACHED ON
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY BETWEEN THE STATE AND
THE SEIU SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION REGARDING
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE BEEN
ASSIGNED TO ASSIST WITH CONTACT.
AND IT APPROPRIATES ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION RELATED TO THESE
PROVISIONS. IT RATIFIED AN
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BETWEEN THE STATE AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS UNITED- OR CCPO
TO ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
LASTLY IT IMPLEMENTS FOUR
HUNDRED TWO MILLION OF THE
FEDERAL CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
AND RELIEF SUPPLEMENTAL ACT WAS
SIGNED IN DECEMBER OF LAST
YEAR- TO MAINTAIN CURRENT CHILD
CARE SERVICES REDUCE PROVIDER
CLOSURES AND ADDRESS THE-
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC. AND
LASTLY SB NINETY FOUR THE SMALL
BUSINESS LICENSING FEE
pBILL APPROPRIATES TWENTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
AND PROVIDES STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
LICENSE RENEWAL FEE WAIVERS TO
ALL LICENSEES OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS. FLORIDA
BARKOV BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY. IT ALSO PROVIDES A
STATUTORY AUTHORITY FOR A TWO
TIME LICENSE RENEWAL FEE WAIVER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWO FOR CERTAIN LICENSEES. OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL PRIMARILY BARS
AND RESTAURANTS- THE ALLOCATION
FOR THAT WAS THE BUDGET BUDGET.
AND I BELIEVE THAT IS THE SWEET
OF THAT ALSO- HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO A- AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MAY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MISS
PADDOCK NEXT. HELLO THE CHAIR-
THIS IS A PRODUCT THEY'LL LET
YOU ANALYSTS ARE WE HAVE A- PER
PREFONTAINE'S BUT I'M HERE
ALONG WITH- MEMBERS OF MY
OFFICE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE NEXT WE'RE GOING
TO GO DO S. EIGHTY SIX OF WE'RE
GONNA ASK MS GABLE FROM OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE JUST
TO. WALK THE MEMBERS THROUGH SB
EIGHTY SIX WHICH IS THE- SCHOOL
REOPENING SAFE IN SCHOOL OPEN
SCHOOLS PLAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GABLE CONSULTANT FOR THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE. AS
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BEGAN SPREADING ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS BEGAN VOLUNTARILY
CLOSING IN ORDER TO PREVENT
FURTHER COMMUNITY SPREAD. OVER
THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
SCHOOLS REMAINED CLOSED FOR THE
PATCHWORK APPROACH TO ONLINE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING AND STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT. AS PART OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED MINIMUM
STANDARDS AND EXPECTATIONS FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING. BUT
EMPHASIZE THE SCHOOLS WERE TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE. IN JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC EALTH
PROVIDED THE FIRST IN A SERIES
OF GUIDANCE SPECIFICALLY FOR
SCHOOLS TO GUIDE THEIR OPENING
AND CLOSING TO DECISIONS AS
WELL AS ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
FACTORS WHEN OPEN. WHAT IS BEEN
THE CLEAR CONTACTS BETWEEN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY AND NOW
IS THE PUBLIC EDUCATORS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO ASSUME THE ROLE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS. IN
ORDER TO SAFELY NAVIGATE WHEN
AND HOW TO OPEN SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
CLEAR STATE LEVEL PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTISE AND STANDARDS ARE
NECESSARY TO RELIEVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION EXPERTS OF THIS TOOL
BURDEN. THE STATE HAS ALREADY
MOVED FORWARD WITH SOME KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH SB EIGHTY SIX
BUT NOT LOCATED IN THE BILL.
CDPH HAS ISSUED FIRM PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE SPECIFIC TO
SCHOOLS IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS REFERENCED IN THE
BILL. THE STATE IS ALSO PROCURE
TWO MONTHS OF PP AND SAFETY
SUPPLIES TO EVERY SCHOOL IN THE
STATE. THE STATE HAS TILTED UP
TESTING CAPACITY TO SUPPORT
SCHOOL COVERED NINETEEN TESTING
DIRECTLY. AS OF THIS WEEK OVER
ONE THOUSAND SCHOOLS IN FORTY
ONE COUNTIES ARE NOW
IMPLEMENTING SCHOOL CENTERED
COVERT NINETEEN TESTING. VIA
THE STATE'S VALENCIA BRANCH
LABORATORY. THE STATE HAS NOW
LAUNCHED THE SAFE SCHOOLS FOR
ALL HUB TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AROUND SCHOOL
TRANSMISSION AND OPENING STATUS
DATA. AND A COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATION EXCELLENCE AND CDPH
CREATE A ROBUST PEDIATRIC
HEALTH AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
CAPACITY AND PROVIDING TA
DIRECTLY TO SCHOOLS SPECIFIC TO
THEIR RE OPENING AND SAFETY
NEEDS. AND THEN MOST RECENTLY
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS ANNOUNCED
HIS GOAL TO HAVE ALL SCHOOLS
SAFELY RE OPEN IN HIS FIRST ONE
HUNDRED DAYS IN OFFICE AND IS
GREATLY INCREASED CALIFORNIA'S
PLANNED VACCINE SUPPLY. AT THIS
CRITICAL JUNCTURE THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
HAS THAT THEY SHARE THE GOAL OF
ACCELERATING SAFE SCHOOL RE
OPENING. AND SB EIGHTY SIX IS
THE LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE
INTENDED TO FACILITATE SAFE
SCHOOL RE OPENING IN EVERY
COMMUNITY THIS SCHOOL YEAR. THE
INTENDED SB EIGHTY SIX IS TO
HAVE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTISE AND CLEARER ENFORCED
COMMON STANDARDS LEAD RE
OPENING DECISIONS IN EVERY
SCHOOL ACROSS THE STATE. THIS
BILL ENCOMPASSES THE THREE
DISTINCT COMPONENTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE SAFE AND OPEN
SCHOOLS PLAN INTENDED TO
FACILITATE A SAFE AND PHASED
APPROACH TO RE OPENING ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. T. K. THROUGH
SIXTH GRADE FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE SCHOOL YEAR.
FIRST PUBLIC HEALTH AND SCHOOL
STATUS DATA AND VACCINES. TO
SCHOOL RE OPENING INCENTIVE
GRANTS. AND THREE STUDENT
LEARNING RECOVERY GRANTS. THE
BILL APPROPRIATES A TOTAL OF
SIX POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUNDS FOR THESE
PURPOSES. THE BILL ALSO MAKES
PANDEMIC RELATED FLEXIBILITIES
FOR THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
EXPENDITURE DEADLINE CHANGES
FOR THE SCHOOL CORONAVIRUS
RELIEF FUNDS THEY HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED. IN CONTRAST THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
INCLUDES TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMPETITIVE RE OPENING
GRANTS AND FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION FOR LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANT. THE STATE HAS ALSO
RECEIVED OVER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR SAY FREE OPENING MEASURING
AND ADDRESSING LEARNING LOSS
AND OTHER ACTIONS TO MITIGATE
THE EFFECTS OF COVERT NINETEEN
ON OUR STUDENTS. SPECIFICALLY
THE PROVISIONS OF SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SIX. ON COULD NINETEEN
VACCINES. SB EIGHTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL DEPARTMENTS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO MAKE VACCINES
AVAILABLE TO ALL SCHOOL STAFF
TO PROVIDE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
OR SERVICES IN PERSON. A FIRM
STEP BEYOND THE STATE'S ONE B.
ALLOWANCES. ON COULD NINETEEN
REPORTING AND PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENTS SB EIGHTY SIX
WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS TO REPORT
EMPLOYEE AND STUDENT CODE
NINETEEN POSITIVE CASES AND
SCHOOL OPENING STATUS. CHOIRS
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS TO
TAKE NECESSARY STEPS TO RESPOND
TO THE POSSIBLE SPREAD OF CODE
NINETEEN CASES ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES. REQUIRES PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS TO POST A
COMPLETED CODE NINETEEN SCHOOL
SAFETY PLAN ON THEIR INTERNET
WEBSITE NO LATER THAN APRIL
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
IT REQUIRES CITY PH TO POST
THIS DATA ON A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE WEBSITE. ON LEARNING
STUDENT LEARNING RECOVERY
GRANTS. SB EIGHTY SIX WOULD
PROVIDE FOUR POINT FIVE SIX
BILLION AND ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS FOR STUDENT
LEARNING RECOVERY GRANTS TO
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
CLASSROOM BASED CHARTER SCHOOL
TO FACILITATE THE LAUNCH OF A
MULTI YEAR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION THE FRONT. IT
PROVIDES A STUDENT LEARNING
RECOVERY GRANTS BASED OFF OF
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WITH A BASELINE FOR
HOMELESS STUDENTS. REQUIRES
ELEAZAR TO PROVIDE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN ORDER TO ACCESS
THE FUNDS. IT DIRECTS FUNDS FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL AND STUDENT
SUPPORTS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO SUMMER SCHOOL
EXTENDED YEAR EXTENDING
INSTRUCTIONAL DATE TIME AND
OTHER WILL IN PERSON SERVICES
SUCH AS ONE ON ONE TUTORING ALL
DEFINED AS BEING SUPPLEMENTAL
TO THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL DAY.
ALLOW SCHOOLS TO USE THESE
FUNDS NO LATER THAN SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT ALLOW
THEM TO USE IT THROUGH
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
REQUIRES THE SCHOOLS RECEIVING
FUNDING IMPLEMENT A TIERED
PROGRAM A SUPPLEMENTAL
INSTRUCTION AND SUPPORT THAT
OFFERS AT A MINIMUM.
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTION TO
PUPILS SUPPORT FOR PEOPLE
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
AND SCHOOL MEALS. ESTABLISHES
MINIMUM STUDENT GROUPS FOR
LEARNING RECOVERY INCLUDING AT
RISK PEOPLE'S STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN CHRONICALLY ABSENT FROM
DISTANCE LEARNING AND
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERPERFORMING
STUDENTS. CREATES ONE PLAN FOR
TWELVE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE OF RE OPENING AND
LEARNING RECOVERY FUNDS FROM
ALL STATE AND FEDERAL SOURCES
TO BE IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. CREATES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CAPACITY THROUGH
EXISTING CD E. AND COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SYSTEMS TO
SUPPORT SCHOOLS WITH THIS
LEARNING RECOVERY STRATEGY. FOR
ON THAT FOR THE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION SUPPORT GRANT
SPECIFIC TO RE OPENING. SB
EIGHTY SIX WOULD PROVIDE TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
GRANTS TO EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND IN PERSON CHARTER TO
FACILITATE A SAFE RETURN TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WITH THE
FOLLOWING CONDITIONS FOR
FUNDING. NO LATER THAN APRIL
FIFTEENTH SCHOOL SHALL OFFER IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR
VULNERABLE T. K. THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE STUDENT GROUPS.
BE A STRICT PUBLIC HEALTH
FRAMEWORK CALLED COHORTS. THIS
REQUIRES SCHOOLS PROVIDE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION TO SMALL
COHORTS OF VULNERABLE TO K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHAT COLOR CHEER
THEIR COUNTY IS IN. VULNERABLE
STUDENT GROUPS INCLUDE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES FOSTER AND
HOMELESS YOUTH STUDENTS AT RISK
OF A NEWBIE OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
STUDENTS LACKING DIGITAL ACCESS
AND DISENGAGED STUDENTS FROM
DISTANCE LEARNING. ADDITIONALLY
NO LATER THAN APRIL FIFTEENTH
SCHOOL SHALL RE OPEN AND T. PAY
THROUGH SIX INSTRUCTION IF
SCHOOLS ARE LOCATED THAT COUNTY
IN THE RED TEAR OR BETTER.
ELEAZAR ALLOWED TO OPEN SOONER
WITH A COVERT SAFETY PLAN
PURSUANT TO CURRENT STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE. IF
SCHOOLS ARE LOCATED IN THE
COUNTY STILL IN THE PURPLE TEAR
AS OF APRIL FIFTEENTH THEY WILL
BE REQUIRED TO OPEN FOR IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR TKA
THROUGH SIX STUDENTS WITHIN NO
MORE THAN FIFTEEN DAYS AFTER
COUNTY ENTERING THE RED TEAR OR
BETTER. SB EIGHTY SIX ALSO
CONTAINS PROVISIONS TO SUPPORT
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE ALREADY
OPENED PRIOR TO THE LATEST CD
PH GUIDANCE. SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
ALREADY OPEN OR HAVE A RE
OPENING PLAN BUT HAVE NOT YET
RE OPENS TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
ARE ALLOWED TO ACCESS SB EIGHTY
SIX FUNDS AND CONTINUE TO
OPERATE UNDER THEIR EXISTING
PLANT. THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SB EIGHTY
SIX AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL OR THIS BILL CREATES A
TWO BILLION DOLLAR BLOCK GRANT
FUNDING CONDITIONS RATHER THAN
A COMPETITIVE GRANT WITH THE
DEADLINE TO MEET. THE
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL ALSO
COMBINES LEARNING RECOVERY RE
OPENING AND FEDERAL GRANTS FOR
A SINGLE TWELVE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLAR. PURSE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND RECOVERY PLAN.
SB EIGHTY SIX REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO SERVE ALL IDENTIFIED
VULNERABLE PEOPLE GROUPS IN
SMALL COHORTS REGARDLESS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TEAR NO LATER
THAN APRIL FIFTEENTH. THIS BILL
REQUIRES SCHOOLS TO REOPEN FOR
T. K. THROUGH SIXTH GRADE
PERSON INSTRUCTION NO LATER
THAN APRIL FIFTEENTH OR ONCE IN
THE RED TIER RATHER THAN
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO REOPEN
FOR TEEKAY TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. ALSO IN THE PURPLE
CARE. THIS BILL CREATES A MORE
SPECIFIC MINIMUM STANDARDS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR LEARNING
RECOVERY GRANTS BASED OFF OF
THE SCIENCE AND EVIDENCE. AND
FINALLY SB EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
TO PROVIDE COVERT NINETEEN
VACCINES TO SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE SERVING OUR PEOPLE'S IN
PERSON. THANK YOU MISLI DID YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENT ON S. B.
EIGHTY SIX. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHANG- I JUST THE JOINT
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FAMILY
AND THE SENATE HAVE REALLY JUMP
STARTED THE SCHOOL RE OPENING
DISCUSSION AND DEMONSTRATES. A
HIGH PRIORITY EACH WITH SUN
RETURNING STUDENTS SAFELY BACK
TO SCHOOL- BASED ON OUR
COLLECTIVE WORK AND ONE MONTH
THE MOMENTUM HAS CHANGED- AND
SHIFTED THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
KIDS WILL GO BACK TO SCHOOL
THIS YEAR TO WHEN THEY WELL.
I'M SAID THIS CRITICAL JUNCTURE
WE BELIEVE WE SHARE THE GOAL OF
ACCELERATING THIS PROGRESS. I'M
AS GABLE MENTIONED ARE IN
JANUARY THE ADMINISTRATION
SHARED A PLAN THAT ACCELERATES
AND SUPPORT SCHOOL RE OPENINGS
FOR OUR YOUNGEST AND MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS AS SAFELY
AS POSSIBLE. THE PLAN CENTERED
AROUND SAFELY REOPENING SCHOOLS
FOR GRADES- OF ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND
INCENTIVIZING ELEMENTARY.
SCHOOLS TO REOPEN BY FEBRUARY.
BOB AND THEY TAKE A OF THE PLAN
HAVE SINCE THEN. VALIDATE BY
SCORING I FROM THE FEDERAL. AND
BY PRESENT CHIEF MEDICAL
ADVISOR DR ANTHONY FAUCI. AND
THE GOVERNOR SAID LAST WEEK SB
SIX DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH. OR
FAST ENOUGH WELL IT DOES
REQUIRE SCHOOLS RECEIVING FUNDS
TO OPEN AND REQUIRES IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION THE RE OPENING DATE
IS BY APRIL FIFTEENTH AND ONLY
FOR SMALL COHORTS THAT
SPECIFIED STUDENTS. AND THIS IS
AT THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES UNTIL
COUNTY CODE RATES DECLINE TO
BELOW SEVEN PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- THIS COULD POSSIBLY
MEAN SOME STUDENTS WILL NOT BE
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM BEFORE
THE END. YEAR I WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO BUILD ON THE
GROWING MOMENTUM. THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT AND OUR SHARED
PRIORITY OF GETTING KIDS BACK
INTO THE SCHOOL- IN SCHOOLS AS
SAFELY AND QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
THANKS THANK YOU MR. CABRAL NO
WAY OUT. YOUR AVAILABLE ACCOUNT
PUBLIC. I DON'T HAVE ANY
PERMITS ROOMS AVAILABLE IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK
YOU I'M OPENING IT UP TO
MEMBERS AND QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
THOUGHTS MR DAHLE. I THINK
YOU'RE MISTER CHAIR AND I WOULD
HAVE TO SAY THAT SB EIGHTY SIX
GET SCHOOLS OPEN. IT'S ABOUT
ACTION NOT JUST DISCUSSIONS-
AND I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE
MISTER CHAIR WE WERE VERY OPEN.
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE SEVERED
ALL ALONG. WE DO NOT. YES SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO THAT IN A
VERY SHORT TERM GET A PLAN
TOGETHER AND GET OUR SCHOOLS
REOPEN IN A SAFE MANNER AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
SKETCHING OUT FUTURE VACCINES
AS A VERY HIGH PRIORITY FOR ME.
YOU LOOK AROUND US. AND WE'RE
NOT AROUND EACH OTHER WORDS
WERE DISTANCE YOU CAN'T JUST
THROW SOMEONE IN A CLASSROOM
FULL THIRTY FIVE KIDS. MAYBE
EVEN HALF AT SEVENTEEN. AND NOT
VACCINATE THEM. WE CAN DO IT.
WE'RE GETTING ABOUT WHAT ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION I THINK THIS
WEEK AND WE JUST SET ASIDE A
CERTAIN PORTION. FOR TEACHERS.
WE CAN GET THEM VACCINATED.
NEEDS TO BE MUCH MORE- MUCH
MORE ARE SUPPORT FOR TEACHER
VACCINATIONS. AND I EVEN HEARD
DOCTOR FELT SHE ON TV YESTERDAY
ON THE SUNDAY MORNING SHOWS
THEY ASKED HIM WHAT. WOULD HE
GO INTO A CLASSROOM AND TEACH.
AND HE WILL ANSWER. SENATOR
TEACHERS THAT'S HOW WE GET
BACK. WE VACCINATE TO EDUCATE.
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE- BE
ACCOUNTABILITY. BUILT INTO SB
EIGHTY SIX A LOT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE SAYING HEY JUST
GIVE US THE MONEY JUST GIVE US
THE MONEY. WELL THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE SAFETY
MEASURES AND ULTIMATELY ABOUT
HOW THAT MONEY IS SPENT ON
LEARNING LOSS AS WELL. SO WITH
THAT I JUST IN SUMMARY. I HOPE
WE CAN SIT DOWN AND FIGURE THIS
OUT THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY
I'M NOT DOWN TO LONG BEACH
TODAY. IS A PRESS CONFERENCE
DOWN THERE I'M NOT THERE I'M
HERE. I'M READY TO CUT A DEAL
AND GET KIDS. BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE THAT'S MY
PRIORITY AS A PARENT OF TWO. AS
A TEACHER AS THE CHAIR. OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER DONALD MR FONG. YES- I
GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION WOULD
BE FOR AARON AND MAYBE ERICA
CAN JUMP IN- SERVICE SO
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE
CONTENT AT THIS BILL WILL NOT
ONLY MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT
THREE OF THEM BUT MAY PUT
BARRIERS IN FRONT OF DISTRICTS
THAT MAY HAVE ALREADY MANAGED
TO BE OPEN AND FOR TRANSPARENCY
AT THE SCHOOL THIS IS IN KERN
COUNTY THERE BUT- SEEKING A
AIVER PROCESS TO REOPEN
QUICKER SO WHAT DOES THIS BILL
OFFERED TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT WILL HELP. THEM BE OPEN
SOONER THAN UNDER THE CURRENT
RE OPENING FRAMEWORK- AND HOW
DOES THIS AFFECT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE GOING TO THE
WAIVER PROCESS WERE AWARDED
CURRENTLY OPEN. STILL MAYBE
ALSO WITH ERIN AND ME AND
AMERICA JUMP IN AFTER THAT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO
THE BILL CONTAINS VERY STRONG
LANGUAGE AROUND MAKING SURE WE
GRANDFATHER IN ALL SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE. ALREADY OPENED OR HAVEN'T
PUBLICLY ADOPTED PLAN TO RE
OPEN BUT HAVE NOT BEEN ALLOWED
TO BECAUSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND CURRENT SITUATIONS IN THEIR
COUNTY SO THE BILL WOULD NOT
PLACE NEW REQUIREMENTS A FOR A
NEW PLAN FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE ALREADY. MADE THAT
PLAN TO RE OPEN EVEN IF THEY
REMAIN CLOSED AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE OF PUBLIC HEALTH- TO
ERICA G. DO YOU SHARE THAT
VIEW. IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS
BILL DOES TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT. ARE IN THE PROCESS OF RE
OPENING OR- OR TRYING TO GET A
WAIVER WOULD THIS. BILL PUT
MORE BARRIERS OR MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT OR DO YOU SHARE THE
SAME VIEW THAT. WAS JUST
OUTLINED. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- MR FONG I THINK THAT-
CURRENT LAW EXISTING LAW
ACTUALLY ALLOWS FOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY. AND I'M GONNA TURN
THIS QUESTION TO MY- COLLEAGUE
JESSICA HOLMES FOR SOMETHING
ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
JESSICA HOME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE CONCERN BUT WE
HAVE- REGARDING THE BILL AND RE
OPENING FOR SCHOOL THAT MAYBE
ALREADY REOPENED OR ALREADY
HAVE A PLAN TO RE OPEN REALLY-
ARE ARE AROUND THE REQUIREMENTS
TO BE OPEN IN RIGHT HERE-
CURRENTLY GUIDE- SCHOOL SAFETY
HELP AND GUIDANCE ALLOWS-
SCHOOL TO OPEN IN PURPLE- AND
ALLOW THEM TO DO THAT IF THEY
HAVE A SCHOOL SAFETY PLAN IN
PLACE- THAT ARE WORKING WITH
THEIR LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS.
WILD BILL DOES NOT TAKE THAT
AWAY- BY SETTING UP A STANDARD
OF AS YOU KNOW THE STATE
REQUIRING RE OPENING- APPLE
LOVES SEVEN PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND CASE RATE UPTICK OF
THE CASE RATE- AND BY SETTING A
DATE OF APRIL FIFTEENTH. IN
PRACTICAL TERMS WHAT THAT CAN
DO IS THAT CAN- LEAD TO- SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND- THEIR LABOR
PARTNERS HAVING TO SIT BACK
DOWN AT THE TABLE AND TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW WHY ARE WE OPEN
NOW IF THE IF THE STATE IS ONLY
REQUIRING- THAT WE THAT WE GO
BACK AND READ- FOR THAT WE WAIT
UNTIL APRIL FIFTEENTH SO I
THINK THAT WHILE. AND THE BILL
DOES NOT PROVIDE THAT YOU KNOW
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK AND
LOOK AGAIN AT YOUR AGREEMENT
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PRACTICAL REALITY IS THAT MANY-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
ALREADY OPEN OR HAVE PLANNED TO
OPEN BEFORE APRIL FIFTEENTH OR
IN PURPLE. MAY FIND THAT THEY
ARE AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW HAVING TO SIT BACK DOWN TO
RENEGOTIATE THOSE AGREEMENTS
AND DUE. TO THE SETTING OF THE
STANDARD. THE SILVER COULD JUST
FALL UP JUST. AT THE PATRICIA
MEAN THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. HAVE HAVE A REAL
FACT IF THIS. DOES LEAD TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHO ARE TRYING
TO OPEN THE DELAYS THAT SO HOW
WOULD THAT BE RESULT. IN FROM
THE MEDICATIONS PRESCRIBED.
PROPOSAL FOCUSES ON REOPENING
MORE QUICKLY AND BECAUSE OUR
PROPOSAL ALLOWED THEN AND IN
FACT THAT THE MINIMUM STANDARD-
RE OPENING IN PURPLE FOR FULL
GRADE. AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT
IS SUPPORTED- AGREEMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE AND
THEREFORE DOESN'T SATISFY AYE
DIFFERENT STANDARDS THAT WOULD
FORCE- FOLKS HIT TO LOOK AGAIN
AT THEIR AGREEMENT SO I THINK
THAT WE STILL VERY STRONGLY
THAT FULL GRAYSON PURPLE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- IT IS.
VERY IMPORTANT AND. SHIPPED TO
PROTECT AT THE EXISTING
AGREEMENT. N. SAID THE- SO I
UNDERSTAND REAR A LOT ALLOWING
AS GOOD AS IT TO OPEN IN FOR
BOTH THE THRESHOLD IS TWENTY
FIVE PER HUNDRED THOUSAND.
CORRECT. BOARD CENTER AND WOOD
OKAY- AND THEN I GUESS THE
SECOND QUESTION I HAVE
CERTAINLY YOU IN REGARDS TO
VACCINATIONS. AND MAYBE THIS
QUESTIONS FIRST ERIN AND THEN
MAYBE I'LL GO BACK TO JUST GOT
UNDER THIS BILL IS IT A
REQUIREMENT FOR TEACHERS AND
OTHER SCHOOL OR DISTRICT STAFF
TO BE VACCINATED BEFORE A
SCHOOL CAN OFFER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. CAN YOU OFFER THAT
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- AND JUST BEFORE I GET
TO THAT QUESTION JUST HURT TO
REITERATE THAT THE CONCERNED
ABOUT A MOVING TARGET AROUND
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS AND WHEN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN OPEN
HAS BEEN A POINT OF CONTENTION
SINCE THE NEW CD PH GUIDANCE
WAS ISSUED IN JANUARY. THE NEW
GUIDANCE WAS EXTREMELY MORE
FIRM AND STRICT THAN ALL PRIOR
GUIDANCE AND HAS CREATED A
CASCADE EFFECT OF HARD
CONVERSATIONS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ABOUT WHEN AND HOW TO
OPEN AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY
NEED TO MEET THIS NEW STRICT
GUIDANCE SO. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THERE IS NO MINIMUM STANDARD
FOR WHEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
HAS TO OPEN SO THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AND THE ASSEMBLY'S
PROPOSAL IN SB EIGHTY SIX IS
THAT WE WOULD OPEN IN PURPLE
FOR ALL VULNERABLE TKA THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENT GROUPS THAT
WOULD BECOME A REQUIREMENT IN
PURPLE REGARDLESS OF THE CASE
RATE SO THAT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. ARE
STARTING TO GET IN PERSON
ENGAGEMENT IMMEDIATELY AND THEN
WE WOULD NOT REQUIRE FULL
GRADES UNTIL THE RED TIER
HOWEVER UNDER CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY ALLOWED TO OPEN AND-
IT WOULD STILL BE A LOCAL
CONTROL CONTROL DECISION ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO
RECONSIDER. WHAT THEY HAVE ARE
DECIDED TO DO WE ASSUME THAT
THE PRESSURE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WOULD MAKE THAT SOMETHING THAT
WOULD NOT HAPPEN. SO GETTING TO
THE VACCINES QUESTION IF YOU
LOOK AT SECTION FOUR THREE FIVE
TWO SIX BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONFUSION IN THE MEDIA
ABOUT WHAT THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL ACTUALLY SAYS. THERE IS NO
REFERENCE IN THE BUILD TO
VACCINES AND THE SCHOOLS ARE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES IT IS
SPECIFICALLY A MANDATE. THAT
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THE BIG PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MAKE THE
COVERT NINETEEN VACCINE
AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL SITE
PERSONNEL WHO WERE WORKING AT A
SCHOOL SITE WHERE STUDENTS ARE
ATTENDING IN PERSON. AND THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT THAT
WHILE TEACHERS ARE ELIGIBLE
CHILD CARE WORKERS ARE ELIGIBLE
UNDER ONE B. WE HAVE DATA BACK
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT
STATE. BOARD OF EDUCATION THAT
SHOWS THAT MANY MANY COUNTIES
INCLUDING OUR LARGEST URBAN
COUNTIES. ARE NOT YET MAKING
THE VACCINES AVAILABLE EVEN
THOUGH IT IS ALLOWABLE UNDER
ONE B. SO THIS BILL WOULD TAKE
THAT STEP TO REQUIRE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO MAKE SURE
THOSE VACCINES ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ALL SCHOOL PERSONNEL. WHO
ARE GOING TO BE INSTRUCTING IN
PERSON AND WE ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL BE A CATALYST.
FOR CONFIDENCE AMONGST OUR
WORKERS TO BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
CAMPUS BUT IT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT. MORE PRESSURE ON
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ITSELF.
SURVISCOR FOLLOW UP AND- IF A
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH. OFFICE
CANNOT MAKE VACCINES AVAILABLE
BECAUSE OF JUST. STATE SUPPLY-
SOMETHING THAT'S OUTSIDE THEIR
CONTROL WHAT RESTRICTIONS AND
WOULD BE PLACED. ON THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THIS IT DOES NOT
PLACE ANY RESTRICTIONS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE LANGUAGE IS
NOT A- A REQUIREMENT FOR RETURN
TO WORK- REQUIREMENT FOR THEIR
PLAN. THERE IS NO WHERE IN THE
BILL WHERE THERE IS AN
INTERSECTION BETWEEN VACCINES
AND IT IS SCHOOL DISTRICT'S
RESPONSIBILITY- HOWEVER WE ARE
VERY IT DISSIPATING IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCEMENT JUST LAST WEEK.
ABOUT ARE GREATLY INCREASING
VACCINE SUPPLY IN HIS
INTERESTING CREATING A SET
ASIDE SPECIFICALLY FOR SCHOOL
SITE PERSONNEL THAT WE BELIEVE
IS CONSISTENT WITH SB EIGHTY
SIX. WE ARE DISSIPATING BUT
OVER THE MONTHS OF MARCH AND
APRIL THAT THERE WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN VACCINE
AVAILABILITY. FOR THESE
TARGETED GROUPS. SUGGEST THE
REQUIRED THIS BILL DOES NOT
HAVE A VACCINE REQUIREMENTS FOR
SCHOOLS EXPERT DISTRICTS TO
REOPEN CORRECT. OKAY SAID
JESSICA NOT TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT BUT I AM IMPROPER PURPOSE
PUTTING ON THE SPOT DO YOU.
AGREE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT IN
THIS BILL. YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION I THINK THAT
THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF-
AMBIGUITY IN THE LANGUAGE AS IT
CURRENTLY IS WRITTEN. AND IT
CAN BE INTERPRETED DIFFERENT
WAYS AND SO WE ARE CERTAINLY
CONCERNED WITH THE LANGUAGE AT
THE THREATEN WE ALSO
QUESTIONED. THE NEED FOR THE
LANGUAGE GIVEN- THAT NOW THAT
THE GOVERNOR MADE- REGARDING
THE FACT THAT WE ARE. GOING TO
ENSURE THROUGH OUR THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENT AT EVERY SINGLE
COUNTY IN THE STATE IS GOING TO
BE PRIORITIZING EDUCATORS.
EQUALLY WITHIN THAT TIER ONE B.
CATEGORY AS WELL AS THE 10%
SATISFIED OR VACCINATIONS FOR
EDUCATORS WHICH WE WOULD JUST
NOTED NOT- SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING FOR ANY OTHER
SECTOR IN THE STATE- SO IT
DEFINITELY PRIORITIZING
TEACHERS- SO I DON'T THINK THAT
WE FEEL LIKE THAT LANGUAGE IS
NECESSARY AND CERTAINLY GIVEN
THE WAY THAT IT'S CURRENTLY
CRAFTING. PROVIDES A LOT OF
CONFUSION TO THE FIELD- ONE
OTHER THING THAT I WOULD JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I KNOW
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IT WORDS CURRENT LAW
ON VACCINATION. AND CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT REQUIRE VACCINATION
FOR EDUCATORS TO GO BACK INTO
THE CLASSROOM AND- ON THE
RECENTLY REALLY FEDERAL CDC
GUIDANCE OFFICE THE COURT THAT
THAT MOTHER ACTIVATION
CERTAINLY- IS ONE PIECE AS-
WHAT CAN BE A YOU KNOW AS- A
MODEL FOR BRINGING. AND
TEACHERS ACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM. REALLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECES OF MEDICATING
COATED FRED ARE THE OTHER
HEALTH AND SAFETY FACTORS
AROUND MASKING SOCIAL
DISTANCING- CLEANING. AND WE
CERTAINLY FEEL LIKE THOSE ARE-
REALLY WELL DESCRIBED AND LAID
OUT IN OUR STATEWIDE GUIDANCE.
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. OKAY SO I JUST SAY
THAT THE- THE CONCERN THAT I IS.
THAT THERE NEEDS TO FEED AND
GRAPHIC. ON THIS- AND THE US
AREA THAT THAT CLEARLY EXISTS
AND TALKING TO BOTH OF YOU- AT
ON BOTH SIDES. THAT YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO ENSURE THAT
DISTRICTS. HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO REOPEN WE CERTAINLY WANT
TEACHERS AND STAFF VACCINATED.
THOUGH COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS ARE AT THE WHIM OF.
STATE SUPPLY AND SO WHAT
CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHER THE-
CERTAINLY ALL OTHER SAFETY
MECHANISMS THAT ARE IN PLACE
OAK TESTING AND- PP AND
SANITATION TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS. A WIDE VARIETY OF RESOURCES
TO ENSURE SCHOOLS ARE REOPENED
BUT- I CERTAINLY WANT TO ENSURE
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO SELL. AND THAT
WE MAINTAIN A PATH. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE PURPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY- TRYING TO BE OPEN OR
WORKING THROUGH THE WAIVER
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO RE OPEN AS
THEY SEE FIT. LOCALLY THAT'S I
THINK MY CONCERN I DO SHARE.
THE CHAIRS- A PERSPECTIVE THAT
WE NEED TO REOPEN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE IN THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WHO CAN OPEN NOW
SHOULD WE OPEN NOW. AND SO I
JUST WANT TO POINT TO ENSURE
THAT- THIS BILL PROVIDES SOME
CLARIFICATION. I HAVE SOME
OTHER QUESTIONS A MOTHER BILLS
BUT ALL THAT ALL AT THE
MEMBERS- PROCEED WITH EDUCATION
BECAUSE DISCUSSION AND I WILL
GO BACK TO THE OTHER BILLS. I
THINK THIS VEGETABLE WILL
DEFINITELY COME BACK TO YOU-
NEXT WE HAVE MISTER- MCCARTY
AND THE. MISTER RAMOS AND THEN
MISSED RUBIO. A THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- MISTER
BUDGETARY. PROMOTION I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE VACCINES- AND
THEN JUST ABOUT THE BIG PICTURE
OF THE DO NO HARM. AND IN SOME
SPECIFICS BUT I GUESS THE BIG
BIG PICTURE IS WIRY HERE
BECAUSE SO MANY OF OUR KIDS.
ARE SUFFERING SUCH GREAT
LEARNING LOSS AT HOME AND MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE HAVE KIDS
AT HOME WHO WERE DEALING WITH
THIS AND- THANK YOU MY KIDS ARE
FIGURING OUT. BUT A LOT OF KIDS
ARE. A LOT OF KIDS WHOSE
PARENTS ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
WHO ARE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY IN THEIR
HOMES- ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE I DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES- YOU KNOW WE'RE
SEEING YOU KNOW A GREAT GREAT
IMPACT THE- PACE JUST RECENTLY
JUST CAME OUT AND SAID THAT
THERE'S AN AVERAGE. 30% DROP IN
ENGLISH AND MATH SCORES THAT'S
ONE THIRD OF ONE. YEAR LEARNING
THAT'S THAT'S TRUE LEARNING
LOSS WE TALK ABOUT THESE
WAIVERS. THERE'S BEEN WAIVERS
FOR A HUNDRED AND TWENTY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. BUT FIVE HUNDRED
PRIVATE SCHOOLS SO WHO'S
GETTING THE BENEFIT OF GOING
BACK. KIDS WHO HAVE RESOURCES
YOU LOOK AT SCHOOLS THAT ARE RE
OPENING IN SACRAMENTO IN MY
REGION. THEY'RE NOT IN OUR AREA
IN THE URBAN CORE. DURING THE
OUTSIDE AREAS. NOT ALL OUTSIDE
AREAS ARE. ARE WEALTHY BUT THE
MAJORITY OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE OPENED THAT. HAVE
RESOURCES SO THERE'S A HUGE
EQUITY IMPACT ON THIS AND LOW
INCOME ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. OUR FOSTER YOUTH ARE
FALLING FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
DOING IT THAT'S WHY WE HAVE.
THE SENSE OF URGENCY AND I WILL
NOT THERE ARE SOME WHO HAVE
QUESTIONED SOME OF THE FINITE
DETAILS AS FAR AS- THE RE
OPENING GRANTS AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WILL DO HARM TO PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY OPEN- I THINK
IT WAS CLARIFIED BY OUR OURS
BUDGET STAFF MEMBER. AND WE ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH THE SENATE TO
DO A CLAIFYING AMENDMENT TO
MAKE SURE. THAT DISTRICTS THAT
ARE OPENING UP AND ARE ON THE
PROCESS. THEY WON'T BE ANY
BURDEN ON THEM WE WANT TO ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE TO DO SO AS
LONG AS THEY HAVE A TWELVE IN
RE OPENING PLAN. LIKE WE TALKED
ABOUT. I WILL SAY THAT THE
LARGEST DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO LOS
ANGELES FRESNO. OAKLAND LONG
BEACH I MAY BE MISSING ONE.
THEY WROTE A LETTER TO US LAST
FRIDAY AND SAID YOU KNOW WHAT.
FUNDS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HELP US RE OPEN AND GET KIDS
BACK LEARNING. I SPOKE TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF LA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT LAST WEEK
REMINDED ME YOU KNOW WHAT. I
LIKE. TO PUSH TO GET MORE
VACCINES IT'S HAPPENING ANYWAY.
TEACHERS ARE NOW GETTING THEIR
LOTTERY NUMBERS CALLED
ESSENTIALLY LIKE WE SEE HERE IN
FACT WENT ACROSS THE STREET AND
ACROSS THE STATE. WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS ASKING PART OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO SPEED UP A LITTLE
BIT MORE. AS A SUPERINTENDENT
LA PETER SAYS GIVE US TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND VACCINES I'LL GET
YOU TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL WITHIN
DAYS. THEIR PARENTS WILL GET
BACK SOME SENSE OF NORMALCY.
THIRTY JUST CAN GO BACK TO WORK
THOSE THEIR COMMUNITIES CAN
REBUILD AND GET THAT GOING SO.
IT'S NOT THAT DIFFICULT AS. AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LONG BEACH
NOTED. YOU KNOW IF YOU THINK
ABOUT BIG DAY WE HAVE FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT GIVEN THE VACCINES TO
KIDS THAT TAKES OUT. ABOUT 25%
OF THE CALIFORNIA POPULATION.
THIRTY MILLION RIGHT. 30% OF
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA ARE SAYING
YOU KNOW WHAT. I DON'T WANT THE
VACCINE I'M TAKING A PASS FOR
WHATEVER REASON NEVER NEVER
ROUGHLY. NORTH OF TWENTY
MILLION ROUGHLY WHO NEED THE
VACCINE WE'VE ALREADY GIVEN OUT
OVER SEVEN. WE'RE GIVING ONE
MILLION A WEEK ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION A WEEK COMING IN THIS
WEEK GRANT WITH THE FIRST DOSE.
BUT WE ARE WELL ON OUR WAY. IT
WOULDN'T BE THAT DIFFICULT. TO
TEACHERS ARTICULAR NUMBERS CALL
ANYWAY TO TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT. AND PUSH IT UP FRONT TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE CAN GET OUR KIDS
BACK LEARNING IT'S NOT THAT
COMPLICATED. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
ASKING THIS BILL. FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE'S NOT A
REQUIREMENTS AGAIN. AND OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD ASK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH AND
FRANCISCO JUST ASKED AS WELL.
THERE'S NOT A PRE REQUISITE THE
TEACHERS GET VACCINATED WE'RE
SAYING WE WANT TEACHERS TO BE
OFFERED NOT JUST TEACHERS BY
THE WAY EDUCATORS STILL. BUS
DRIVERS CLASSIFIED WORKERS
INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES PEOPLE AT
THE SCHOOL SITES. AS MIGHT AS
BUDGET CHAIRMAN TING ALWAYS
MENTIONS THERE'S LESS THAN SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL SCHOOLS AND
ANOTHER GOING BACK TO WORK. SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND BOTH MET WITH
A MAYBE HALF OF THOSE WE NEED.
THAT'S LIKE. OF A QUARTER OF
THIS WEEK'S SHIPMENT TO GET SIX
MILLION KIDS BACK LEARNING OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY WHY WON'T
WE FOCUS ON DOING THAT THAT'S
ALL WE'RE FOCUSING ON AND
ASKING. IN THIS BILL- THAT THAT
THE MONIES THAT WE PROVIDE
REALLY PROVIDE A ROAD MAP. FOR
DISTRICTS TO RE OPEN AND TO
MAKE SERVER FOCUSING ON MATTERS
MOST- LEARNING LOSS OVER THE
NEXT YEAR AND A HALF. I KNOW
WE'RE DOING SOME SOME TWEAKS
WITH THE SENATE TO CLARIFY SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT CAME UP
EARLIER. I WISH WE'RE VOTING ON
THIS LATER TODAY IT'S TIME. I
KNOW WITH THAT WITH THAT WE ARE
HEARING IT TODAY THE
INFORMATIONAL ITEM LIKE WE
ALWAYS DO. IN BUDGET COMMITTEE.
ON OUR TRAILER BILLS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO VET THESE
THINGS THROUGH AND- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY WILL BE VOTING ON
THIS IN THE- FLOOR IN THE
COMING DAYS AND I CERTAINLY
HOPE WE CONTINUE TO TALK WITH
ADMINISTRATION THEY EMBRACE-
THIS BECAUSE THAT I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE THAT FAR APART. BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IS THE FAR PART
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR STATE.
AND WITH FAMILIES AND OUR KIDS
MISSING OUT SO IT'S TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER MISTER BUDGET SHARE.
THANK YOU MISS MCCARTY MYSTERON
US. MISTER CARE LESS FOR THE-
BRING UP IN IN- IN TRAILER BILL
EIGHTY SIX- TALKING ABOUT THE
TESTING THAT- BEING ASKED AT
THE DISTRICTS AS ONCE THEY THEY
REPORT POSITIVE TEST WITH THE
FUNDING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW WITH THAT PAY FOR THE
TESTING THAT THE SCHOOLS WOULD
HAVE TO MINISTER. YES THE AND
TEND TO THE LEGISLATION THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO UTILIZE BOTH THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS AS WELL AS
THE IN STATE FUNDING AS WELL AS
THE SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THE
RECEIVING TO LEVERAGE SOME OF
THAT FOR ANY TESTING COSTS. IN
OF THE FUNDING- GETS EXHAUSTED
DURING THE TESTING COMPONENT
THAT'S NOW BEING. INCURRED UPON
AT THE LOCAL LOCAL DISTRICTS
WOULD. FURTHER RESOURCES COME
FORWARD- TO OUR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS- THE
DISCUSSION IN THE CRAFTING OF
THIS BILL IS THAT WE WOULD NEED
TO POTENTIALLY REVISIT ALL
KINDS OF RE OPENING COSTS AND
LEARNING LOSS COSTS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE SENATE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THE JUNE
BUDGET. SO THIS WOULD BE THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE IN THE
FUNDING BEHIND THAT IN ORDER TO
OPEN SCHOOLS THIS SPRING SO
THANK YOU HAVE A MAJOR STANDING
IT CORRECT AND IF THEY DO
EXHAUST THAT FUNNY THAT'S THERE
IT WILL BE REVISITED- IN THE
JUNE A DISCUSSION DURING THAT
BUDGET- DISCUSSIONS DURING
THOSE TIMES. THAT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING YES SIR THANK YOU
MY BEST A COMMENT AND THANK YOU
FOR IDENTIFYING THE HOMELESS
STUDENTS- WITH ON PAGE TWENTY
TWO OF THE BRIEFING THAT'S
THERE. AND ALSO WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS THAT WERE THERE
THAT THAT MONEY'S GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED TO THOSE REAS WILL
THAT BE ABLE TO BE USED FOR THE
LOCAL SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE TO-
WORK WITH THE COUNSELORS SO
THAT THOSE AT. OUR STUDENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
CLOVER NINETEEN AND SEEING
EVERYTHING THAT LIKE WE'RE SEEN
AS ADULTS THAT THEY HAVE THE
PROPER RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH
THAT A MOTIONAL- I BELIEVE
TRAUMA AND MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENTS. WELL AS WE BRING
THE STUDENTS BACK TO SCHOOL.
CURRENTLY UNDER SB EIGHTY SIX
IT'S NOT JUST- ALLOWABLE TO BE
SPENDING THE FUNDS ON
COUNCILLORS STAND- AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS IS ACTUALLY
REQUIREMENT THAT THE PLAN FOR
LEARNING LOS ADDRESS THE SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL WELL BEING. OF
THE STUDENTS UNDERSTANDING THAT
WERE COMING FROM A PLACE. OF
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA AS WELL AS
LEARNING LOSS. SO IF WE NEEDED
TO USE SOME OF THAT FUNDING TO-
RE- RETOOL SOME OF THE
COUNSELORS TO THE SPECIFIC
NEEDS OF WHAT WE'RE CHALLENGE
WITH TODAY. THAT MONEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO YOU'D BE USED IN THAT
IN THAT AREA YEAH THAT. YES
THANK YOU- ANOTHER QUESTION IS
FOR OUR SPECIAL- NEEDS STUDENTS
AND POPULATION I SEEN ON. ON
PAGE TWENTY FOUR ITEM ONE.
WHERE MONEY IS BEING ALLOCATED
TOWARDS OUR SPECIAL NEEDS- A
POPULATION WITHIN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND CERTAINLY MENTAL
HEALTH IT'S THAT AREA MAKING
SURE THAT CANCERS ARE QUICK. TO
DEAL WITH WITH STUDENTS IN THAT
CATEGORY ALSO. BUT THE QUESTION
WOULD BE- IS- ADRS INCLUDED IN
THAT FOR ALTERNATE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION MONIES THAT COULD BE
USED ALSO. FOR SOME OF THOSE
CASES. CURRENTLY THAT SB EIGHTY
SIX DOES NOT HAVE AN
APPROPRIATION FOR- ADDRESSING
ADDITIONAL ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE
NEEDS. FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AROUND THAT WERE AROUND
COMPENSATORY EDUCATION
PRESSURES. THAT IS A
CONVERSATION WE WILL NEED TO BE
HAVING AS PART OF THE JUNE
BUDGET YES SO THAT DISCUSSION
WOULD MOVE FORWARD- IN THE JUNE
BUDGET BUT- THEM. BUT WE DO SEE
IT AS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED AS WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD AND OPEN UP THE
SCHOOLS. YEAH CALIFORNIA YES
SEE THAT'S WHY YOU SEE FOR THE
MANDATORY COHORTS YOU SEE ASTON
TO SPECIAL NEEDS IDENTIFIED
REGARDLESS OF THE COLOR OF
THEIR COUNTIES TEARS SO THE
STUDENTS CAN BE. OFFERED IN
PERSON RE ENGAGEMENT
IMMEDIATELY. AND THEN ALSO SEE
THEM AS A- REQUIRED- STUDENT
GROUP WITHIN THE LEARNING LOS.
I RECOVERY GRANTS THEMSELVES.
WITH A KID AS WE MOVE FORWARD-
MISTER CHAIR TO OUR OUR JUNE-
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS I WOULD LIKE.
TO CONTINUE TO BE- OF THE ON
WHERE THESE DISK ARE. UP INTO
THAT. MISTER I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION ON SB EIGHTY SEVEN IF
NOW'S APPROPRIATE TIME
ABSOLUTELY. WELL THANK YOU- AND
I SEE THAT AND- SB EIGHTY
SEVEN. THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
LICENSE- LICENSES WAIVERS. FOR
PARTICULARLY- FOR THE
COSMETOLOGY LICENSES THAT ARE
THERE. BUT I KNOW THAT IN MY
DISTRICT THERE'S BEEN FAR MORE
ON BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN.
IMPACTED RIGHT COSMETOLOGY AS
ONE HOSPITALITY- SOME OF THE
OTHER AREAS THAT HAVE THE
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED. SO THE QUESTION IS
HOW DO WE COME. TO LOOK AT THE
COSMETOLOGY AND GETTING THOSE
FEES- LICENSE RENEWALS THERE
BUT NOT EXPAND INTO SOME OF THE
OTHER- INDUSTRIES AND
COMPONENTS I GUESS THE MATRIX.
THAT WAS USED TO COME UP WITH
THAT DECISION. THANK YOU MISS
MISS LIAM PRODUCT. HI THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- IN
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE WAY FOR WHO WANTED TO
LOOK AT THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT
WERE MOST IMPACTED BY- BUSINESS
CLOSURES DUE TO HEALTH AND
SAFETY CONCERNS REGARDING THE
PANDEMIC AND- WE HAVE
COSMETOLOGISTS BARBERS
MANICURISTS AESTHETICIANS
ELECTRO JEFF- IN PARTICULAR THE
THEY THEY ARE FOCUSED THERE'D
FOCUS HERE AND PARTS OF THE WAY
FIRST BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED-
JUST AS AN AS A NO THERE'S FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD FALL
UNDER THIS. THE LABOR- AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
ESTABLISHMENTS. SO QUITE A FEW
INCIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
YET AND WAS ANY CAN. GIVEN TO-
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE OUT
THERE ARE TWO SMALL BUSINESSES
WHERE I'VE SEEN IN MY DISTRICT.
SOME ACTUALLY AGO WONDER
BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT OF COLD
IT AND IS THAT TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. WHEN THE WAIVERS
AND ALL THESE THINGS ARE BEING
DISCUSSED. YES THAT SECONDARY-
COMPONENT OF THE FEE WAIVER IS-
FOR BARS AND RESTAURANTS
SYSTEMS SMALLER BUSINESSES-
THERE'S ABOUT FIVE FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND LICENSEES THAT WOULD
FALL UNDER THAT. EXCEPT THANK
YOU IT AND MOVING TO THE JUNE
BUDGET IF WE IDENTIFY- MORE
AREA SPECIFICALLY TO OUR
DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE WOULD- WOULD LIKE TO
BRING THOSE FORWARD THROUGH THE
CHAIR TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
BUSINESSES ARE ACTUALLY BEING
PART OF THE DISCUSSION AS WE
TALK ABOUT THE TRUE IMPACT THAT
BUSINESSES ARE HAVING HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MR THANK YOU MISTER ROBERTS
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MISS RUBIO.
AND THEN- MISS RIVAS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FROM A FEW OTHER
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED BY
I WANTED TO JUST TO REITERATE-
SOME OF THE POINTS I REPRESENT
ELEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND I%
AM AND THEY L. A. COUNTY- KIND
OF AREA BUT JUST. WANTED TO
CLARIFY SO BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING NEW
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REQUIREMENTS WHAT HAPPENS IF
THOSE DISTRICTS DON'T COME INTO
AN AGREEMENT- ARE THEY STILL
REQUIRED TO. WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IF THERE IS NO AGREEMENT.
YES THIS IS BEEN A COMMON-
POINT OF CONFUSION WE'VE HEARD
OVER THE WEEKEND FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THERE IS NO- REQUIRED
NEW BARGAINING AGREEMENT UNDER
THE BILL. SO WHAT THE BILL DOES
IS IT RECOGNIZES EXISTING
BARGAINING LAW AND ASK THAT
THAT BARGAINING AGREEMENT BE
SENT TO THE SIN TO THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO BE ON
FILE. SO THERE IS NOTHING IN
THIS BILL- OUT THAT'S ABOVE AND
BEYOND EXISTING LABOR LAWS THAT
WOULD- ALLOW BARGAINING UNITS
TO BE WORKING WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ON WHAT THEY BELIEVE
IS THEIR SAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS SO FOR THOSE THAT
ALREADY HAVE. ADOPTED AGREEMENT
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE IN HERE-
AND SO IT ALLOWS THEM TO
RESPECT THE AGREEMENT THEY'VE
ALREADY REACHED THE STANDARDS
THEY'VE ALREADY REACHED. AND
THEN FOR THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW NEEDING TO
STILL BARGAIN AND GET THAT
PROCESS COMPLETED THEY HAVE A
DEADLINE OF GETTING THAT
COMPLETED BY APRIL FIRST IN
ORDER TO POST THAT- ON THEIR
WEBSITE PUBLICLY. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE OPENING ON APRIL FIRST. OKAY
SO THEN THEN THE NEXT QUESTION
IS- CAN I SEE ARE THE NEXT
COMMENT OR QUESTION IS CAN I
SAFELY TELL MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
I HAVE A SUPERINTENDENT
ROUNDTABLE ON THURSDAY CAN I
STAND SAFELY SAY THAT WE WILL
ALL BE OPENED- BY APRIL
FIFTEENTH. I'M AYE THAT'S A
WONDERFUL QUESTION THE- BILL
SETS A MINIMUM STANDARD IT'S A
DEADLINE FOR WHICH SCHOOLS HAVE
TO MEET IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN RE
OPENING FUNDS. SCHOOLS ARE
ALLOWED TO OPT OUT UNDER THE
BILL AS IT IS WRITTEN AND SO.
IF AN ALLEY A FOR WHATEVER
REASON CONTINUES TO BELIEVE
THAT THEY CANNOT AND WILL NOT
BE OPENING THEY WILL FORFEITED
THEIR SHARE OF THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. RIGHT BUT THEN I CAN'T
TELL MY PARENTS THAT ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL BE OPENED BY BY
APRIL FIFTEENTH. CORRECT
ANSWERS NOW I CANNOT CORRECT
THIS IS AN INCENTIVE NOT A
MANDATE OKAY. AND THEN- ALSO IN
TERMS OF THE VACCINATIONS- WERE
VACCINE WHERE THE GOAL IS TO
VACCINATE ALL THE TEACHERS ARE
ALL THE EDUCATION. EDUCATION
WORKFORCE CORRECT- BUT- HOW ARE
WE TRACKING ARE WE GOING TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE DISTRICTS THEY
WILL BE RE OPENING. OBVERSES
THOSE THAT THAT WON'T BECAUSE-
IF WE'RE IF WE HAVE A MINIMUM-
AMOUNT OF VACCINES. AND SOME
DISTRICTS ARE NOT GOING TO OPEN
A WE'RE GOING TO BE VACCINATING
THAT GROUP VERSUS THE ONE THAT
ARE RE OPENING- BASED ON THE
GUIDELINES. YES THANK YOU THAT
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY THE
LANGUAGE IT SAYS SPECIFICALLY
IT'S FOR A PERSONALITY- ARE
PROVIDING IN PERSON SERVICES.
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW THAT THERE
IS A VERY WIDE RANGE OF
PERSONNEL- COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROFESSORS- FOLKS IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT ARE I'M NOT
PLANNING TO BE OPEN BECAUSE OF
COMMUNITY SPREAD AND THERE ARE
ELIGIBLE UNDER ONE B. SO THIS
IS SPECIFICALLY. SAYING THEY
ARE PROVIDING IN PERSON
SERVICESIN ORDER TO HAVE THIS
EXPDITED- AVAILABILITY TO THE
FRONT LINE SO YOU WILL BE
TRACKING ON THOSE THOSE
DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO
BASICALLY PUT IN A REQUEST- TO
USE SAME WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN
CAN YOU VACCINATE ALL OVER
EDUCATION WORKFORCE. SO THE
BILL DOES NOT PUT ANY KIND OF
REQUIREMENTS OF US SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TAKE A LEADERSHIP
ROLE THAT WE KNOW SO MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN AND HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO WORK WITH THE COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
ORDER TO LEVERAGE VACCINATION
DAYS OF APPOINTMENTS FOR THEIR
STAFF. THERE'S NOTHING IN THE
BILL THAT REQUIRES THEM TO DO
THAT- BUT IT IS ABSOLUTELY
SOMETHING THAT THEY COULD WHAT
O. WITH DOES IS IT RICK. THAT
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH. OFFICER
TO BE A PARTNER AT THE TABLE
MAKING THOSE VACCINES AVAILABLE
FOR INDIVIDUAL PERSONAL. OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN THE OTHER ON
THE QUESTION- IS. THE SO I
GUESS IT'S THE SAME KIND OF
QUESTION. THERE IS CONFUSION AS
WHO HAS TO ARE WE OPEN BY APRIL
FIFTEENTH I HAVE AN EMAIL FROM
MY KIDS SCHOOL THAT K. TWELVE
R. K. SIX IS OPENING THIS WEEK
AND THE MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS- WON'T OPEN UNTIL
AT LEAST APRIL FIFTEENTH. IS
THAT A SET STANDARD OR IS IT
DIFFERENT FOR DIFFERENT AREAS-
HOW DOES THAT WORK YES SO THIS
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE ANY
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE
THAT HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SO THE GUIDANCE THAT THEY
PUBLISH THAT WAS VERY CLEAR IS
A MINIMUM FLOOR FOR SAFETY. IN
JANUARY- THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO IT AT ALL TIMES IN HERE BUT
NOT MAKING ANY CHANGES SO THE
CONDITION FACT WHAT THE BILL
SAYS IS THAT SCHOOLS ARE
ALLOWED TO OPEN UNDER PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE YOUR REGARDLESS
OF THIS BILL SO IF THEY ARE
TAKING THE INCENTIVE FUNDING
NOT TAKING INCENTIVE FUNDING
THEY STILL NEED TO FOLLOW
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDELINES. OKAY
AND THEN- MY CONCERN IS THE
LANGUAGE SAYS SHALL YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING'S AS SHALLOW AS
OPPOSED TO WELL AND THAT'S
WHERE THE CONFUSION IS AND SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE EITHER WE
CAN CLEAR UP THE LANGUAGE OR IF
I CAN ASK- JESSICA WHAT THEIR
INTERPRETATION IS ON BASED ON
BOTH BOTH TERMS SHALL. WHATEVER
THE NEXT STOP THE SENTENCES BY
THE SHALL IS ALWAYS AN ISSUE
BECAUSE SHALL MEANS VERY MAY OR
MAY NOT AND SOLD IF I CAN HAVE-
JESSICA YOU KNOW GIVE ME HER
INTERPRETATION ON. THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU JUST
PROVIDED I'D APPRECIATE THAT.
IF SHE'S AROUND STEP. A YES AS
CALLED TO PER OF FINE AND I
THINK I. A LITTLE BIT OF THE
AFFECT THAT. IF THE SHOW. AND
WE'RE TO BE. WHICH PIECE OF THE
BILL A COUPLE A COUPLE OF THE
ISSUES THAT SHALL VACCINATE-
YOU KNOW AND THEN SHALL RE
OPEN- A LOT OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT I'M SEEING HAS THE WORD
SHALL AND- YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S
BASED ON INTERPRETATIONS OF
SOME. DISTRICTS WILL NOT COMPLY
BECAUSE OF THE WORD SHALL OR-
YOU KNOW OTHERS THAT WANT TO
DESPERATELY RE OPENED WELL BUT
HOW DO WE- IS YOUR
INTERPRETATION THE SAME THAT
EVERYBODY WILL BE AT SOME
POINT- YOU KNOW UP AND RUNNING.
SO- EIGHT DAYS OUR TRADITION OF
SB EIGHTY SIX IS THAT AND IT IS
AN INCENTIVE SO THAT THE SHALL.
AT THE SHALL. ENTER THE SCHOOL
RE OPENING APPLY TO THOSE WHO
WOULD BE RECEIVING GRANT
FUNDING AND THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT- THEY DIDN'T MEET THAT
REQUIREMENT BUT THEN. FOR STATE
SOME OF THAT GRANT FUNDING- BUT
IT'S NOT NOT A SHALL INDEED
MANDATE TEN SQUARE REGARDLESS
WHETHER NOT THEY CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GRANT THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO REOPEN TO
BUT- I THINK OUR OUR
INTERPRETATION ALIGNS WITH
WHAT. AND WHAT NOT THE STABLE
AND- DESCRIBED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE. THANK YOU
MISTER RUBIO GOT MISS A REVERSE
AND THEN THIS THERE. I WANT TO
BY THANKING CHAIR MY COLLEAGUES
FROM LONG BEACH IN SACRAMENTO-
AND OTHER MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE AND THIS
NEGOTIATION TO OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS- SAFELY- I REALLY
BELIEVE WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
TEACHER SAFETY AND- NOT JUST
TEACHERS BUT SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
THEIR SAFETY AND WE SHOULD
PRIORITIZE- VACCINES FOR THEM
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES. THAT
HAVE BEEN HARD HIT BY COBIT
LIKE THE AREAS THAT I REPRESENT
SO I REPRESENT COMMUNITIES IN
LOS ANGELES WHERE THE CASE
THERE'S ONE IN FIVE- CASES OF
COALBED. IN RESIDENTS BUT YET
ONLY 829% OF THESE COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED COMPARED
TO OTHER AREAS OF LOS ANGELES
THAT ARE MORAL WEALTHY COMPARED
TO MINE WHERE. MUCH LOWER CASE
RATES BUT HIGHER VACCINATION
RATES UP TO TWENTY NINE
PERCENT. ARE AND THAT CONCERNS
ME WHEN WE THINK OF OUR SCHOOS
ARE WE GOING TO TREAT SCHOOLS.
IN OUR LOW LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE THEY GOING TO
BE LAST LIKE OUR SENIOR
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN LAST IN MY
COMMUNITY. IN OUR VACCINATION
PLAN AND SO I JUST WANT TO
BRING THAT UP I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN SOME ARTICLES THAT HAVE
BEEN PUBLISHED RECENTLY. ABOUT
THE DISPARITIES IN OUR
VACCINATION PLAN ESPECIALLY IN
BLACK AND LATINO COMMUNITIES-
AND I HOPE THAT THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN IN SCHOOLS THAT- WHERE
THE MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ARE
BLACK AND LATINO AND- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS
AND BRING THAT UP BECAUSE THIS
IS THE TIME. THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT AND
PLANNING FOR THIS- SO THE I
HAVE ONE QUESTION RELATED TO-
PP. I'M DOES ANYONE HAVE
BACKGROUND IN FUNDING FOR P. P.
E. IN SCHOOLS. I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT. SO WE CAN ABSOLUTELY GET
YOU SOME INFORMATION ON THAT
THE- PP REQUIREMENTS APPLE
CLARIFIED IN THE JANUARY
DEPARTMENTS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE THAT WE'VE BEEN
REFERRING TO SO WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY SEND YOU WITH THAT
IS AT SEVEN VERY. CLEAR
STRAIGHTFORWARD PP IT HAVE
GUIDELINES FOR ITS SCHOOLS
SPECIFICALLY. BUT THE
GUIDELINES DO YOU MEAN THAT AND
WHEN COULD THE FUNDING SWEAR
HOW THE SCHOOLS WILL RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR THAT OKAY SO- IN
TERMS OF THE OF IT JUST AS
BACKGROUND SO. THAT STATE
PROCURED TWO MONTHS WORTH OF PP
FOR ALL SCHOOLS AND SENT IT OUT
DIRECTLY THROUGH THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN THE
SPRING. THEN WE ARE IN THE
BUDGET ACT HAD ALLOCATED OVER
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR- RE
OPENING AND DISTANCE LEARNING
COSTS ABOUT 11% OF THAT FUNDING
WAS SPENT ON A RE OPENING TYPE
COST LIKE PP WE CAN GET YOU THE
SPECIFIC NUMBERS. AND OTHER
THAN THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
REPORTING YET FROM THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT WHAT ELSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MAY HAVE BEEN
SPENDING IN TERMS OF THEIR PP
NEEDS- BUT WE DO KNOW THAT IT'S
A WAS ABOVE WHAT ADAM HAS BEEN
PROVIDED SO FAR. OKAY WELL LET
ME JUST SEE IF MISS LEAR MISS
HOLMES ONCE AFTER THAT. I CAN
ADD I CAN ADD TO. AND WHAT NEWS
GABLE I THANK YOU BY SAYING
THAT THE STATE HAS ALSO
PROVIDED AND- AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR THEY
PROVIDED THAT WE PROVIDED SIXTY
DAYS WORTH OF. PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES TO SCHOOLS. AND ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON PROVIDING
ANOTHER THIRTY DAYS WORTH OF
PPP AT NO COST TO SCHOOLS- IN
ADDITION- THAT THE FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION. I THINK THAT
DIDN'T GIVE A WAS REFERRING TO
THAT WE PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT WILL CONCERT
WE USE- YES SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
FOR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT- THE SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. IN FEDERAL- AS AFTER
AND SORRY IT THAT DAY- BUT I
COULDN'T STAND FOR THIS EVENING
HERE RIGHT NOW BUT- SAID AFTER
FUNDS THAT HE GOT TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND THOSE
ARE BEING. ALLEN SCHOOL THE
THIS TIME YOU'VE ALREADY THE AT
THE OUT. FOR THE PART EDUCATE
TO GET THE OUT TO SCHOOL THE
NEXT OFTEN BE- FORTY. WELL
HAPPEN SIX DOLLARS IN SYSTEM.
MATTER IN REGARD TO- THE-
QUESTION OR EQUITY ALONG MAXINE.
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT ON THE
STATE'S. PLAN FOR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION REALLY DOES HAVE A
MASSIVE ACT EQUITY COMPONENT-
AND- USING IT DIRT PARTY
MINISTRY OR TO BE MORE
CONSISTENT ACROSS THE STATE TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES I JUST
WANTED TO. MAKE SURE THAT THAT
WAS CLEAR. I'M I UNDERSTAND
THAT WE SAY THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUITY COMPONENT BUT I'M
LOOKING AT THE DATA. AND THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES HAS JUST
RELEASED OF DATA VACCINATION
RATES BY CITIES AND COMMUNITIES
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES- AND
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HARDEST HIT BY COALBED HAVE THE
LOWEST VACCINATION RATE IN IN
L. A. COUNTY. AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WHAT IT IS ACROSS THE
STATE I'M FOCUSED ON LOS
ANGELES BECAUSE THAT'S THE AREA
THAT I REPRESENT- AND SO WE
COULD SAY. THAT WE HAVE AN
EQUITY PLAN BUT- I NEED TO SEE
THE NUMBERS. AND WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR A FEW MONTHS- WE
HAVE BROUGHT THESE CONCERNS TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AS
LEGISLATORS FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AND WHAT AS
LEGISLATORS WE ARE STILL
WILLING TO PARTNER WE CAN HELP
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- MY TEAM AND
I KNOW OTHERS. ARE READY TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
VACCINATION RATES ARE HIGHER IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
HARDEST HIT BY POVICH. AND WE
CAN'T JUST SAY WE HAVE AN
EQUITY PLAN BUILT IN AND NOT
AND THEN RELEASE NUMBERS THAT
SHOW THAT THAT IS NOT THE CASE-
ED YOU KNOW I HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR AND THEY
HAVE BEN VERY RESPONSIVE TO MY
CONCERNS. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- BUT- WE NEED TO DO MORE
BECAUSE THE NUMBERS. AS WERE
RELEASED THIS WEEKEND DO NOT
SHOW THAT THE STATE HAS AN
EQUITY PLAN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS REAVIS FOR GOING TO GO
TO MISFIRE DERIS AND THEN MR
MEDINA. THANK YOU- GETTING
STUDENTS BACK TO IN PERSON
LEARNING- IS LONG OVERDUE AND
I'VE RECEIVED HUNDREDS. OF
COMMENTS AND- REALLY STORIES
FROM PARENTS AND TEACHERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE IT IS GETTING US A STEP
CLOSER TO OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING. WITH
EVERY VISIT THE TESTING CADENCE
BECAUSE IT IS. AN IMPORTANT FOR
MY DISTRICT ARE IN MY DISTRICT
I HAVE SOME SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
BEEN OPERATING UNDER WAIVERS
SINCE FALL SOME SCHOOLS WHO
WERE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE-
THEY'RE APPROVED WAIVERS- WHICH
THEY DIDN'T ACTIVATE BECAUSE OF
THE SURGE. OR THEN PULLED-
BECAUSE OF THE JANUARY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH OR TWENTY FOURTH-
GUIDELINE CHANGES SO THERE'S
ALREADY FRUSTRATION WHAT I
WOULD DON'T WANT TO HAPPEN IS
FOR OUR SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ALREADY OPEN. TO RUN INTO
PROBLEMS AGAIN- THAT ARE GOING
TO CREATE MORE COMPLICATIONS
FOR THEM PART OF- WHAT MY
QUESTION IS AROUND IS A TESTING
KIT AND CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN
AGAIN. WHAT SCHOOLS HAVE TO
ADOPT. HAVE TO UTILIZE THE
TESTING. CADENCE REGIMENT. YES
OF THE WEAPONS OF THE- THE
TESTING CADENCES THAT ARE PART
OF THE CDPH GUIDELINES WOULD BE
REQUIRED FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY ALREADY
HAVE AN ADOPTED PLAN TO RE OPEN
SO THE GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE
THAT I REFERRED TO EARLIER IS
INTENDED TO AND LEGALLY WOULD
PROTECT A SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
ALREADY HAS AN ADOPTED PLAN
EVEN IF THEY HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT BECAUSE OF
THE TEAR THAT THEY ARE IN AND
IT WAS UNSAFE TO OPEN. SO THIS
FUND IS. A LOT MORE COMPLICATED
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR SEVEN
THROUGH TWELVE. SCHOOLS UN IS
THERE A AND ON TOP OF THE
TEARS- SO FOR HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE UNLIKE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS WHEN TEARS.
WHEN CASES GET TO TWENTY FIVE
PER ONE HUNDRED. THEY CAN THEY
CAN OPEN NOW FOR HIGH SCHOOLS
AT SEVEN. PER ONE HUNDRED- I
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A SERIOUS
LOOK AT THIS. OUR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE COMMITTING
SUICIDE. AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE SERIOUSLY
NEED TO CONSIDER IS MAKING IT
EASIER. AND LESS COMPLICATED
FOR OUR HIGH SCHOOLS AND JUNIOR
HIGHS TO OPEN AS WELL. MY NEXT
QUESTION IS- IS THERE IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT EXIST FOR IN
PERSON LEARNING WHAT DOES IN
PERSON LEARNING MEAN IS THERE A
MINIMUM DOES THAT MEAN THAT YOU
KNOW A SCHOOL COULD ONLY BE YOU
KNOW IT HAVE IN PERSON LEARNING
AN HOUR A WEEK OR IT'S KIND OF
I DON'T SEE ANY CLEARLY ENOUGH
WHAT THAT MEANS. YES THERE ARE-
DEFINITIONS IN THE CURRENT LAW
THAT ARE NOT CHANGED IN SB
EIGHTY SIX RUN THE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES
THAT NEED TO BE PROVIDED DURING
THIS SCHOOL YEAR SO WE DID
CHANGE THAT IS PART OF THE
DISTANCE LEARNING MODEL SO
THOSE MINUTES IF NOT YET
CHANGED WHAT WE DO HERE IS TO
FIND IN PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR
TKA THROUGH SIX IS BEING UNDER
THE IMMEDIATE PHYSICAL
SUPERVISION OF A CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEE AND THEN FOR- OLDER
GRADES FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
FOR HIGH SCHOOL IN THE-
PHYSICAL AND- AS SPACE OF EIGHT
EITHER A CERTIFICATED OR
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE. TO ALLOW-
FOR SAFER CONCORD TAKING OF
THOSE OLDER GRADES WHILE
KNOWING THEY HAVE MULTIPLE
TEACHERS SO KNOWING THAT THEY
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO BE IN THE
PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF IT OF EACH
OF THEIR TEACHERS THROUGHOUT
THE DAY. AND THE REQUIREMENT
THAT 10% OF EXPANDED LEARNING
TIME GRANT FUNDS TO BE SPENT ON
PARA PROFESSIONAL STAFF. MY
DISTRICTS ARE CONCERNED THAT IT
COULD CREATE ARBITRARY AND
UNNECESSARY ONGOING FISCAL
OBLIGATIONS ON WHY NOT GIVE
DISTRICTS MORE FLEXIBILITY
WITHOUT SPENDING. SO THE I'M
INTENT IN SB EIGHTY SIX IS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
EMPHASIS ON- THE ADULTS TO
STUDENT RATIOS THAT ARE
NECESSARY NOT JUST FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH PURPOSES- UNDER THE
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE BUT ALSO
TO TRULY ADDRESS LEARNING LOSS
AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A LOT
OF THE- CALL OUTS AND AROUND TO
BRING. IN ONE ON ONE
INTERVENTIONS AND OTHER KINDS
OF SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS. THE
UNDERSTANDING IS THE
SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS MEAN
SUPPLEMENTAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS
SO- WE ACTUALLY ANTICIPATE A
LARGE MAJORITY OF THE LEARNING
RECOVERY FUNDS BEING UTILIZED
FOR CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES- THERE WAS A GREAT
NUMBER OF LAYOFFS THAT HAPPENED
IN THE SPRING FOR A PAIR
PROFESSIONALS IN PARTICULAR
THOSE WHO PROVIDE. ONE ON ONE
SUPPORT FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS AND SO WE DO
ANTICIPATE MANY MANY ELEAZAR
BRINGING BACK THAT STAFFING
CAPACITY IN THIS NEXT YEAR IF
THERE IN PERSON IN ORDER TO
MEET THE BASIC NEEDS OF THEIR-
STUDENTS EYEPIECE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA GO TO MR
MEDINA THE MYSTERIOUS. SHARE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. ONE OF
FOLLOW UP ON MY COLLEAGUES WHO
ASKED ABOUT TESTING- BOTH THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN AND SB EIGHTY
SIX BOTH- MANDATE TESTING.
SOMETHING THAT MY LOCAL- SIZE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT A ONE THE
HIGH COST OF TESTING. AND
SECOND A SOMETHING THAT I
APPRECIATE AS A FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND THAT IS
THE LARGEST LOGISTICS OF
TESTING. HOW HOW WILL-
KINDERGARTEN TO SIXTH GRADERS-
BE ABLE TO DO TESTING SO. IS
THERE A SOMEONE WHO MIGHT BE
ABLE TO DESCRIBE FOR ME WHAT
TESTING MIGHT LOOK LIKE- IN IN
A SCHOOL IN A CASE SIX A SCHOOL
WHAT WHAT WOULD TESTING LOOK
LIKE HOW IT'D BE ACCOMPLISHED.
HI CAN I AM TURNOUT QUESTIONS
MY COLLEAGUE JESSICA HOLMES.
UNDER THE WHOLE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO AND I AM NOT-
ADMITTEDLY AT A PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERT BUT I BELIEVE I CAN
PROVIDE SOME. THEN- INFORMATION
THAT COULD BE HELPFUL IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THIS LOOKS
LIKE AND THE ANSWER IS REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE TYPE OF TESTING
THAT- DIFFICULT DISTRICT AND
HAD ALL PROCURED OR AT THEIR AT
THEIR STUDENTS AND TEACHERS-
THEY'RE DIFFERENT KIND OF PASS.
AND SOME OF THEM I THINK THE
MAJORITY OF THE ONES THAT I'VE
HEARD THAT ARE BEING USED COOL
OUR CAT THERE- THAT YOU USE THE
Q. TIP BUT YOU JUST PUT AT THE
FRONT OF YOUR NOSE- AND
ACTUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS AND THE VIDEO
ON ITS WEBSITE. I TRAINING
VIDEOS FOR TEACHERS AND PER
STUDENT- THAT LIKENS IT TO YOU
KNOW A CHILD TAKING THEIR NOTES
NETWORK- AND DAD AND IN THOSE
CASES AND IF IT'S BEING DONE ON
CAMPUS THE STUDENT WORKS BUT
PUT THE THOUGHT IN THEIR NOSE.
INTO AT AT SOME KIND OF- SHARE
YOUR HOLDER BAG AS YOU KNOW
THAT CONTAINER I'M IN A BILL TO
BE SHIPPED OFF BY THE BY THE
POOL TO THE LAB FOR TESTING ON
THE OTHER YOU KNOW ANOTHER
PRETTY- POPULAR OPTION AND THAT
MANY FOLKS ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF. IT AT HOME TESTING WHERE
FAMILIES AND TEACHERS AND
ANYONE WHO'S BEEN TAPPED ON THE
CAMPUS JUST GET ON AS A SORT OF
PATH THAT IS. SPECIFIC FOR THEN
THEY TAKE IT HOME THEY CAN DO
THE TASK AND THEN DROP IT OFF
WHEN THEY COME TO SCHOOL AND
THEN WILL PRESIDENT
COLLABORATORY FOR TESTING- BUT
THAT LIKE I SAID THERE ARE MANY
DIFFERENT KINDS OF TASK- IT
REALLY DEPENDS ON. WHO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS CONTRACTED
WITH FOR THE TESTING- AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THEIR PREFERRED
METHOD FOR WHAT THEY HAVE AND
WHAT THEY HAVE AGREED TO AND
WITH THEIR LABOR PARTNERS. TALK
ABOUT GIVES YOU A SENSE SOME
SENSE OF WHAT THAT COULD LOOK
LIKE BUT AGAIN IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT ACROSS THE STATE.
I WOULD JUST SAY. AGAIN AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER. THE SOUNDS
GOOD BUT IN REALITY THAT'S
SOMETHING ELSE AT THAT CAN.
FIRST GRADE TO ADMINISTER THIS
TEST- I THEIR OWN I IS SORT-
LOT TO OF KINDERGARTENERS AND
FIRST GRADERS AND WITH THIS
TESTING THEN WE SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED WEEKLY.
PURSUANT TO THE CURRENT STATE
GUIDANCE- AND PURSUANT IF YOU
ARE PROPOSAL OKAY MINISTRATION
PROPOSAL FOR RE OPENING AND
DOES THE TESTING WOULD BE
REQUIRED WEEKLY FOR- FOR
SCHOOLS THAT ARE OPEN IN THE
PURPLE CURES THAT WOULD BE THE
HIGHEST HERE- THE INFECTION
RATE. AND IF THE SCHOOL DID
CHOOSE TO DO IT AT THE SCHOOL
SITE. WOULD THAT BE THE TEACHER
WHO WOULD THEN BE COLLECTING
THESE TESTS FROM STUDENTS. I DO
KNOW THAT THERE ARE AND IF IT'S
NOT ON THE COOL SIDE SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF IT'S AT HOME- AS YOU
COULD BE SOMEONE IN THE FRONT
OFFICE OR LIKE A DROP BOX FOR
PEOPLE CONSTRUCT THEIR CAST
OFFS THAT THEY'VE DONE AT HOME
AFTER THAT THERE ARE SOME LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WHO HAVE
CONTRACTED WITH. A MOBILE
TESTING UNIT TO COME TO THE
SCHOOL SITE AND INSTEAD OF
HAVING INTERACTION BETWEEN LOOK
BACK ON AND FAMILIES- DATE
THERE'S JUST INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE FAMILIES- OR THE
TEACHERS AND THE LOCAL TESTING
STAFF SO THERE ARE DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT MODEL COURT
DEPENDING ON THE PREFERENCE IN
OUR- OF THE L. E. A. M. I WOULD
JUST POINT OUT THAT. THAT THIS
REALLY CAN CREATE A LOGISTIC
NIGHTMARE OF FOR SCHOOLS AND
AS- SOME OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS.
IN MY AREA POINTED OUT. SCHOOLS
REALLY DO A DIFFICULT TIME NOW.
YOU KNOW JUST GETTING THE FIRST
GRADERS KINDERGARTENERS TO
BRING AND THEIR- THE
VACCINATION RECORDS RIGHT NOW
SO THAT PUTTING. THAT TESTING
ON THEM I REALLY THINK THAT IS-
REALLY GOING TO PUT. SOMETHING
THAT I'M NOT SURE- SCHOOLS ARE
CAPABLE OF DOING. AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WERE GONNA GO TO-
MISS RAAS IN THE MISTER JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
HI I SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING ELSE I
THINK IT HELPS US TO THINK
THROUGH WHAT IT IS WE'RE
PROPOSING WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON
WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING. SO THAT
IS OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO
SAYS THE QUESTIONS WERE ABLE TO
AT LEAST RESPOND IN A IN A
BETTER WAY. I THINK OUR IT'S
CLEAR THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING DURING THIS
PANDEMIC- OVER THIS LAST YEAR
WE WATCHED ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
WIDEN ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND OUR STUDENTS OF
COLOR. WE'VE SEEN AN INCREASE
IN STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AS WE JUST AS WAS DISCUSSED BY
MY COLLEAGUE WHO HAS TAKEN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN THIS REGARD
MIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE HAS WIDENED EDUCATIONAL
INEQUITIES FOR STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO LIVE IN
AREAS WHERE THEY HAVE LIMITED
INTERNET ACCESS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
THE CHAIR OF EDUCATION ABOUT
THE FACT THAT AS LEGISLATORS WE
HAVE TO GET OUR STUDENTS BACK
TO CAMPUS WE HAVE TO DO THIS IN
THE SAFEST WAY POSSIBLE AND
LOOK AT THE SAFETY PROTOCOLS
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF OUR
TEACHERS OR ADMINISTRATORS OR
STUDENTS AND THEN. IT ALSO
TALKED IT'S THE FAMILIES ALSO
THAT RECEIVE THE STUDENTS BACK
HOME. WE'RE ALL HEARING ALL
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE AND I DO
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT. WE
MUST CONTINUE DOING EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND THAT IS TO
COME TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE TO
CREATE A SOLUTION THAT WORKS
FOR OUR TEACHERS OUR PARENTS.
AND OUR STUDENTS. I KNOW THAT
MANYSTILL MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS
AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED HERE HAVE
ALREADY MADE PROGRESS IN
GETTING BACK TO LEARNING SAFELY
IN THE SPIRIT OF COOPERATION
WITH TEACHERS THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. MY COLLEAGUE HAS
TALKED ABOUT SAMPOERNA DINO-
I'M REALLY PROUD OF THE EFFORT
THEY HAVE MADE THE GOOD FAITH
EFFORT. TO CONTINUE THIS
MOMENTUM TO TRY TO GET OUR
SCHOOLS REOPENED. BUT I ALSO
SINCE THE FIRST STRIP
FRUSTRATION. AND IN THE
COMMENTS BY MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS THE VARIOUS-
SCHOOL DISTRICTS MIGHT YOU
MIGHT. MY SOMEBODY DISTRICT.
THEY TALK ABOUT ISSUES
REGARDING TESTING PROTOCOLS
THEY TALK ABOUT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING REQUIREMENTS EVEN
FOR THEIR GRANDFATHERED SAFETY
PLANS THE TALK ABOUT THE
CONFUSION REGARDING WHETHER OR
NOT VACCINES ARE PRECONDITION.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE CONFUSION
AROUND WHO MUST OPEN WHO CAN
OPEN ON APRIL FIFTEENTH. THESE
ARE ALL LEGITIMATE CONCERNS AND
I THINK THAT AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS BEING ABLE TO
ANSWER THOSE. IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE DO KNOW WE SENSE
THEIR FRUSTRATION. I DO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR. I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK ON A PLAN
THAT'S- GOING TO GET OUR
CHILDREN AND TEACHERS BACK. TO
THE CLASSROOM IN THE SAFEST WAY
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU MR. THANK
YOU MR ROSE WILL GO TO MISTER
JONES SAWYER. AND THEN TO MISS
GARCIA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
BUT I JUST WANT TO ECHO WHAT IS
ALREADY BEEN TALKED ABOUT.
WHICH IS THE MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR STUDENTS IF THEY COME BACK
I JUST WANTED TO BE MISSED.
THAT OUR- YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOW.
PROBABLY IN THE MOST STRESSFUL
SITUATION THAT THEY'VE EVER
BEEN. EVEN IF YOUR PARENT GOES
TO WORK IN MY DISTRICT WE HAVE
MANY FACTORS THAT HAVE SPREAD
CALVET AMONG THE WORKERS. IN MY
DISTRICT YOU HAVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT ONLY
DEALING WITH WITHOUT CRYING BUT
THEY'RE ALSO DEALING WITH WERE
NOT PEOPLE BE EMPLOYED. WHEN I
TO BE LIVING IN YOUR HOME AND
THESE LITTLE KIDS WHOSE
STOMACHS ARE PROBABLY TURNING.
EVERY DAY SINCE THIS PANDEMIC
BEGAN. AND IN. THE STRIKE THAT
WAS DONE IN TWENTY NINETEEN-
EARLY UNIFIED TEACHERS SAID
THAT WE NEED MORE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS SOCIAL WORKERS
PSYCHIATRISTS AND NURSES TO
DEAL WITH TRAUMA THE TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE THAT'S NEEDED IT
WAS NEEDED DESPERATELY TWO
YEARS AGO. CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW
IMPORTANT IT WILL BE NOW YES
IT'S GREAT THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
VACCINATIONS IS GREAT WE KEEP
OUR TEACHERS SAFE. BUT THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF OUR STUDENTS
COMING BACK. MAY BE GREAT
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE THAT WE NEVER HAD
TO DEAL WITH BEFORE WITH BEFORE
SO I AM JUST REITERATING TO THE
TO THE ADMINISTRATION. AND
EVERYONE ELSE THAT IT IS GREAT
THAT WE GETTING EVERYONE BACK.
BUT IN MY DISTRICT. AS STUDENTS
COME BACK AND TALK ABOUT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- THE CRIME
RATE ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO SHOOTINGS HAVE GONE UP THAT
THEY'VE BEEN ENCLOSED IN ONE
AREA FOR SO LONG ARE NOT- THE
FRUSTRATION OF NOT BEING ABLE
TO USE THE INTERNET NOT BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH DISTANCE LEARNING.
GET BEHIND IN YOUR CLASSES FOR
A VERY LONG TIME IT'S GOT TO BE
UNBELIEVABLY FRUSTRATING FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN LAW STUDENTS
OF COLOR. BUT NOW THEY'RE
COMING. JUST TO BE PLACED IN A
SEAT. AND NOBODY'S REALLY
DEALING WITH. THE TRAUMA. THE
EXPERIENCE A LOT I HOPE THAT
NOT ONLY ADMINISTRATION BUT
THIS BODY. MAKE SURE THERE'S
ENOUGH FUNDING AND ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO THAT SO THAT WE'RE
NOT BACK HERE IN A YEAR TALKING
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES IN
MIND MONEY WE NEED TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW AHEAD OF
TIME WE SHOULD WHICH IS TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM TWENTY. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA. THANK YOU I'M HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS AND A LOT OF
QUESTIONS A LOT OF QUESTIONS
I'VE BEEN ASKED ALREADY BUT- I
JUST WANTED TO GET THE STEP A
MOMENT AND TAKE A STEP BACK AN
THINK ABOUT THE ROLE OUR
SCHOOLS PLAY. OUR TEACHERS PLAY
ARE CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES PLAY
IN OUR STUDENTS LIVES AND OUR
SOCIETY OUT THERE. WE ARE ALL
TALKING ABOUT ARE GETTING THEIR
STUDENTS BACK BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE THINK ABOUT THE
MANY ROLES THAT ARE. TEACHERS
PLAY I WAS A MATH TEACHER FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS AND MY JOB IS
NOT JUST TO TEACH A CORE DATA
FORMULA OR NUMBERS. A SPACE A
LITTLE BUT PROVIDE A WHOLE-
SUITE OF SUPPORT FOR OUSTED AND
FAMILIES OUT THERE WE'VE ASKED.
ARE IN. MAKE ADJUST AND HAVE.
TO ADJUST TO- VIRTUAL LEARNING
AND THEY HAVE TO ADJUST TO A
BLENDED SYSTEM AND THEY HAVE.
WE'RE ASKING THEM NOW TO RETURN
TO THE CLASSROOM AND AS A
TEACHER AND ALL MY FRIENDS ARE
TEACHERS THEY'RE READY TO GO
BACK TO THE CLASSROOM THEY KNOW
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT. BUT
THEY ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE PROTECTED AND THEN
I BRING SOMETHING HOME TO THEIR
FAMILIES ALONG THE WAY. AND SO
AS WE MOVE BACK THINGS UP AND
MOVE THEM TO THE LIST I ON MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S EQUITABLE. I
HAVE FRIENDS WHO TEACH IN SOME
OF THE HARD HIT COMMUNITIES- MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY AND MY COMMUNITY I FEEL
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR SISTERS
AND BROTHERS AND THINGS
STRUGGLE OUT THERE EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE SEPARATED BY MANY
FREEWAYS. ALONG THE WAY BUT WE
ALSO HAVE SOME OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF INFECTIONS OF DEBTS
THAT SOME OF THE LOWEST RATES
OF VACCINATION IN MY HOME TOWN.
WHAT ABOUT 7% THAT'S NATION
RATE OF OVER THE TOP TEN MOST
AFFECTED CITIES- IN L. A.
COUNTY OUT THERE. BUT IT'S NOT
JUST THAT THE INEQUITIES DEEPER
WE KNOW WE HAVE A DIGITAL
DIVIDE YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
EDUCATIONAL GET THAT'S ONLY
BEEN GROWING. AS I WAS REALLY
AT THIS I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT ENSURING THAT
THE SCHOOLS IN THE HEART OF THE
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED AFTER FRONT OF THE
LINE. FOR VACCINES AND I TO
FIND A LINE TO GET THE TEACHERS
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
BECAUSE THEY WE'VE ALL OF THEM
WERE VERY FOLLOWING NOW IF I
EQUITY AT THE OF EVERY
DISCUSSION FOR A YEAR. WE'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE ANYTHING
EQUITABLE SEEING SCHOOLS IN
PREDOMINANTLY HIRING COMMUNITY
OPEN UP ALREADY- AND WE'RE
GONNA BE AT THE END OF THE LIST
ONCE AGAIN AND SO. AS WE DO
THIS WE NEED TO THIS IN A SAFE
WAY. IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT WE
ARE PREPARED SUPPORT. EDUCATORS
AND SCHOOLS BE SIX. AND THAT
WERE PARTNERS THEM. AND SO
AFTER A LOT OF THE NOW AGAIN
ONE MORE TIME. OF DAY I THINK
IT'S A- WE DON'T FORGET THE
ROLE THAT. AND THERE WAS. THAT
THE SOME. THIS OUR- AND THE
RESPECT THAT THEY- TO BE. WITH
US. WITHIN MINUTES. WITH
LEGISLATURE OUT THERE. THERE
NOT A SINGLE TEACHER IT'S- TO
WHO. DOESN'T SEE THEM. OF OUR
SCHOOLS. OUT THERE BUT THEY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
SO. I HAVE. TO SAY THAT I TALK
TO TEACHERS IN MY BACKYARD AND
THEY'RE LIKE WE WANT TO GO
BACK. WE ARE STRUGGLING THE
KIDS ARE STRUGGLING. BUT
THEY'RE AFRAID WHEN THEY SEE
THE RATES OF INFECTION CIVIL
ART AND- LIKE YOU KNOW HOW MANY
OF YOU ARE AFFECTED I SAID YES
YOU KNOW WHAT. THURSDAY I'M
AFRAID TO WALK OUT THE DOOR TO
WALK MY DOG. SENSING FAT AND
DAY- AND NOT THE WAY OF.
KEEPING MY MORE BY. THEY FOR A
REGULAR. LIKE TOO MUCH THE
STRESS YOU HAVE AS RESCUE TO.
BACK AND SAY I THINK THEY GO
SHE'S. CONTINUE THE SYSTEM WE
HAVE HASN'T BEEN. I OTHER
MINORITY IN A LONG TIME THAT IS
THE- YEAR. WE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO RETHINK AND TO DO A- BUT
YOUR ONLY GO TO DO ABOUT. IF
YOU'RE AT AT. IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING
AND TALKING TO US BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO IDENTIFY
PROBLEMS AND WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO GIVE YOU
SOLUTIONS. BUT LET ME BE CLEAR
I HAVE NEVER FELT LIKE WE'RE
HAVING THE CONVERSATION TO ME.
I IN ANY OF THIS PROCESS OUT
THERE. I'LL I WANT TO BE YOUR
PARTNER. I WANT ADMINISTRATION
TO BE. ATTENTIVE TO MY
COMMUNITY AND AT THIS TIME
THIS. HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO GIVE. YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER. AND THEN. TALK TO
WORK. SORRY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- I THINK FIRST I WANT
TO AGREE WITH THE CHAIRMAN'S
COMMENTS I THINK AT THE
BEGINNING THIS IS WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY- THERE WAS
MONIES EXPENDED IN THIS LAST
BUDGET THAT WENT OUT TO EVERY
SCHOOL. AND THE REALITY IS SOME
SCHOOLS DID A LOT BETTER JOB
THAN OTHERS AT ATTEMPTING TO RE
OPEN. AND SPENT THOSE VITAL
DOLLARS TO HELP GET YOUR KIDS
BACK INTO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
AS BEST AS POSSIBLE. AND
LARGELY THAT WAS IN RURAL AREAS.
LIKE I REPRESENT. MANY SCHOOLS
AND IT'S NOT THAT THEY HAVE
LOWER CASE RATES I HAVE TO
COUNTIES HAD THE HIGHEST TEST
POSITIVE HIGHEST TEST
POSITIVITY RATE IN THE NATION.
AT ONE POINT. SO HAD HIGH RATES
OF TRANSMISSION. BUT THEY FALL
THE SCIENCE. CDC YOU SAID
MONTHS AGO THAT YOU CAN SAFELY
REOPEN YOUR SCHOOLS WITH
MODIFICATIONS. AND SO MANY OPEN
WHEN THE HIGH AND A HYBRID
SYSTEM WITH MODIFICATIONS THEY
BUT THEY HAD TO EXPAND THE
MONIES TO MAKE SURE THEIR
SCHOOLS WERE READY AND THEY
COULD DO THE PP AND ALL THE
DEVICE AND- ALL THE THINGS THAT
WENT ALONG WITH IT. AND YET IN
THIS. IN THIS BUDGET BECAUSE OF
THE LCF FORMULAS IT IS. THESE
SCHOOLS GET UNDERFUNDED
SIGNIFICANTLY. AND IF WE'RE
GONNA GO ON THIS ONE OF MY
BIGGEST PROBLEMS WITH THIS BILL
RIGHT NOW AS IT IS IF WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND SEND THAT SAME
MONEY BACK OUT TO DISTRICTS ON
THE LCF FORMULA. THOSE RULES
RULES SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO GET
UNDERFUNDED AGAIN AND EVEN
GROSSLY. EVEN MORE GROSSLY
DISPROPORTIONATE WAY WHEN THEY
ACTUALLY MANY OF THEM WERE THE
ONES THAT SPENT THE MONEY TO RE
OPEN WELL SOME OF THE VERY
LARGE URBAN DISTRICTS DIDN'T
OPEN AT ALL AND TOOK THOSE
FUNDS JUST AS THE CHAIRMAN
SAID. TOOK THOSE FUNDS DID NOT
REOPEN IT WAS NOT
ACCOUNTABILITY SO WE NEED TO
MAKE THAT RIGHT AND THERE'S
BEEN TALKS ABOUT THIS ALREADY
IT NEEDS TO GET IN THIS BILL
ABOUT EQUALIZE FUNDING IN A
MINIMUM FUNDING FOR THESE RURAL
SCHOOLS. WHO TALKED ABOUT MAYBE
UNDER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT THEY SHOULD HAVE A
MINIMUM FUNDING LEVEL TO
EQUALIZE THE DISPROPORTIONATE
FUNDING THAT IS THE RESULT OF
PUTTING THIS OF A PORTION IT
OUT ON LCF FORMULA. ALONE THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY TALK ABOUT EQUITY. IN
ENSURING THAT BECAUSE WE ALL
EVERY SCHOOL FACE THE SAME
THINGS. WITH COVER NINETEEN.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE TREATING
SOME DISTRICTS AND GIVING THEM
LESS MONEY TO DEAL WITH THAT
SAME VERY ISSUE ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY WERE THE ONES THAT DID THE
WORK TO RE OPEN WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THE PROBLEMS IS REALLY.
INCONSISTENCY AND I WANT TO GO
BACK- TO. THE ADMINISTRATION.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
IMPEDIMENTS TO RE OPENING RIGHT
NOW IS THE BLUEPRINT FRAMEWORK.
QUITE FRANKLY. AND IT WAS SAID
EARLIER THAT- UNDER PURPLE TIER
THAT ALLOWS SCHOOLS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO RE OPEN THAT'S
NOT TRUE. AND K. THROUGH SIX
CAN OPEN UNDER A WAIVER. THAT'S
IT BUT IS IT NOT TRUE WHEN I
WAS ASKING A MINISTRATION THAT
SIX TO TWELVE. IF YOU DID NOT
REOPEN YOUR SCHOOL IN THE FALL.
WHEN IT WAS IN RED DEER. IF YOU
ARE IN THE PURPLE TEAR RIGHT
NOW YOU CANNOT REOPEN YOUR
SCHOOL. UNDER PURPLE TEAR FOR
SIX TO TWELVE IS NOT CORRECT. I
HAVE A QUESTION TO JESSICA
HOPELESS. YEAH AND JESSICA HOME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- AGAIN
AS NOT A PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERT
BUT AND IS IN REGARD TO THE SIX
THROUGH TWELVE QUESTION- YOU
CAN OPEN THE FOR COHORT MOSCOW
COURT A STUDENT- AND- CASE RATE
PURSUANT TO THE CURRENT
GUIDANCE IF YOU ARE ABOVE
TWENTY FIVE- BUT SHIFTED REMIND
FOLKS YOUR CONTACT AND- THAT
PER. THOUSAND POSITIVE TEACHER
UNDERSCORE AND THEN IF YOU'RE
ABOUT. TWENTY HUNDRED THOUSAND-
THAT'S CURRENTLY A DELL- THE
GREAT SIX WHICH. IN RIGHT HE
YOU CAN HELP YOU CAN UP C
HùI BUT YOU CAN DO A HIGH RE
OPENING AT IN PURPLE TO YEAR
CAREER. WELL GREAT BUT IT'S YES.
RIGHT SO THIS IS THE DISPARITY
THAT WE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SO
SCHOOLS THAT RIO IN HIGH IN THE-
AND THERE'LL. TO SAY OPEN. AS
LONG AS THEY OPEN IN THE FALL
ALL THESE COUNTIES ARE IN TEAR.
THERE'S STILL IN PURPLE TEAR
BUT SOME. SCHOOLS ARE ALLOWED
TO BE RE OPENED UNDER THEIR
METRIC. BECAUSE THEY RE OPEN IN
THE FALL BUT IF YOU DIDN'T
REOPEN YOU CAN'T REOPEN NOW.
IMAGINE THAT. THE DISPARITY
THERE THEY'RE THEY'RE THE SAME
TYPE OF SCHOOLS. SO IT'S EITHER
OKAY TO OPEN IN PURPLE OR IT'S
NOT BUT AS THERE'S NO
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE BOARD SO
I HAVE DISTRICTS THAT ARE READY
TO RE OPEN. SIX THROUGH TWELVE
AND THEY CAN'T DO IT BECAUSE
THE PURPLE TIER SYSTEM
FRAMEWORK. WHICH RIGHT NOW THIS
BILL DOES NOTHING ABOUT. AND I
THINK WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT THIS TIERED
FRAMEWORK IS CREATED
INCONSISTENCIES AND DESPITE
DISPARITIES ACROSS. IT'S A GOOD
THIS IS THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN IS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR GOT TO SET
THIS UP ARBITRARILY USING HIS
OWN PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS.
HIS OWN SCIENCE AND NONE OF US
WERE INVOLVED IN THAT
DISCUSSION AND THOSE AND NOW WE
HAVE SCHOOLS THAT. SAME
COUNTIES. SAME RISK. BUT SOME
GET TO BE OPEN AND SOME DON'T.
THAT'S WRONG YOU KNOW WE NEED
TO FIX AS IT. DISPARITIES WE
ALSO I MEAN TESTING TESTING IS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER DISPARITY
AND WE BROUGHT IT UP TODAY. SO
UNDER THIS BILL IF YOU OPEN
BEFORE MARCH FIFTEENTH OR IF
YOU'RE ALREADY RE OPENED. OR IF
YOU HAVE A PLAN BY MARCH
FIFTEENTH. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TEST. NO TESTING REQUIREMENTS.
HOWEVER IF YOU IF YOU'RE A
SCHOOL THAT IS UNABLE TO REOPEN
FOR WHATEVER REASON MAYBE THEY
DON'T GET IT TO A BARGAINING
AGREEMENT WITH YOUR LOCAL
UNION. IN TIME. BUT IF YOU'RE A
DISTRICT THAT COMES AFTER MARCH
FIFTEENTH. YOU ARE GOING TO BE
UNDER THE TESTING REQUIREMENTS
WHICH IS WEEKLY IF YOU'RE A
PURPLE TIER AND EVERY TWO
WEEKS. UNDER READ HERE. NOW IS
THAT CORRECT I'M JUST GONNA ASK
BOTH ERIN. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT CORRECT.
WITH WITH THE A CAVIAR THAT IF
YOU WERE IN THE PURPLE TEAR
THAT THERE IS A PROCESS OF THE
BILL BY WHICH YOU HAVE TO RUN
YOUR A SAFETY PLAN BY THE
SCHOOL SAFETY. TEAM THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED THE STATE LEVEL-
IT'S TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
ADEQUATE FOR SAFETY PURPOSES.
CORRECT RIGHT BUT IF YOU IF YOU
ARE ALREADY OPEN. FOR YOU HAVE
A PLAN BEFORE MARCH FIFTEENTH
YOU WILL NOT HAVE TO TEST DO A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING CORRECT. IF
YOU HAVE ALREADY HAVE A PLAN
ADOPTED IN PLACE REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER YOU'VE OPENED BY MARCH
FIFTEENTH YOU DO NOT HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE NEW CD PH A
SYMPTOMATIC TESTING CURRENT AND
IF YOU'RE A SCHOOL THAT DOESN'T
AFTER. YOU WILL HAVE TO NOTE
THERE'S NO IF ANDS OR BUTS
ABOUT IT YOU WILL BE TESTING.
RIGHT THAT IS WHAT IS IN THE
GUIDANCE YES OKAY.
ADMINISTRATION DO YOU DISAGREE
WITH THAT IS THAT WHAT THIS
PROVIDES. WE DON'T DISAGREE
ALTHOUGH I WOULD NOTE THAT AND
THE PURPOSE BEHIND AND- YOU'RE
GRANDFATHERING IN FOLKS WERE
OPEN- IS THAT THEY HAVE A TRACK
RECORD THAT WE CAN LOOK AT IN
TERMS OF HEALTH AND SAFETY THE
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY HAVE
HAD OUTBREAKS THERE LOCAL. I'M
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH WOULD GO
IN AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOUR OR ASK THEM TO
CLOSE- FOR IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION- HOWEVER IF THEY'VE
BEEN OPERATING WITHOUT
OUTBREAK- FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
THAN IT IT AND THEY'VE BEEN YOU
KNOW COMPLYING WITH HEALTH AND
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS. WHEN THEY
HAVE THAT AND HISTORY AS BEING
OPEN AND BEING UNSAFE IN PERSON
THAT- YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
DISRUPT- FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT HISTORY OF
BEING OPEN AND SAFE AND SO
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE. HEALTH AND SAFETY
PARAMETERS TEMPLATE THAT ARE
NOT JUST ARBITRARY THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BOTH BY THE OF THE
CDC AS WELL AS MANY SCIENTIFIC
REPORTS WE HAVE POSTED ON OUR
WEBSITE. AND TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN OPEN RECENTLY AND NOT
CALLED OUTBREAK THE NON THAT
THAT IS REASONING. THAT OKAY
LONG LONG ANSWER BUT SAME
RESULT GUYS YOU'RE GOING TO
SOME. THAT WILL REQUIRE TO DO A
SYMPTOM TEST. AND OTHERS THAT
WERE HAVE. A AND OTHERS THAT
WERE HAVE TO. WRITE AND THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO USE VITAL. THAT
WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT TO PAY
FOR THAT TESTING. YOU'RE GOING
TO CREATE A DISPARITY THERE AND
IT'S A DISPARITY THAT WE DON'T
NEED. BECAUSE CDC DOES NOT
REQUIRE YOU TO DO TESTING. CDC
DOES NOT REQUIRE YOU TO DO A
SYMPTOMATIC TSTING AND THE
EXPERIENCE ACROSS THE NATION.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN OPEN IS
THAT YOU CAN OPEN SAFELY
WITHOUT A SYMPTOMATIC TESTING
AND WE HAVE NOT SEEN OUTBREAKS.
AND IN FACT THE FACTS ARE. IN
THOSE SCHOOLS THE RATE OF
TRANSMISSION IS MUCH LOWER THAN
WHAT WE SEE IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND AGAIN CITY SEES BEEN SAYING
THIS FOR MONTHS DOCTOR FELT YOU
HAD A MUCH PUBLICIZED.
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
HIMSELF. WHERE HE SAID YOU CAN
SAFELY REOPEN SCHOOLS EVEN
WHERE YOU HAVE HIGHER RATES OF
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION. AND THE
GOVERNOR SAID HE UNDERSTOOD
THIS AND YET HE HASN'T CHANGED
THIS IN HIS CDPH GUIDELINE
PROTOCOL. AND HE'S GOING TO
REQUIRE SCHOOLS THAT ARE THAT
ARE UNFORTUNATE ENOUGH. TO GO
AFTER THAT MARCH FIFTEENTH DATE
AREN'T OPEN IN SCHOOLS TO THEN
ABIDE BY THIS TESTING PROTOCOL
THAT ISN'T NECESSARY. AND THAT
IS COSTLY. SO WE NEED TO STOP
HAVING THESE DISPARITIES THAT I
THINK A LOT OF US HAVE HAVE
TOUCHED ON YEAH IT IS SAFE TO
OPEN SCHOOLS WE KNOW THE
MITIGATING STRATEGIES SCHOOLS
ARE ALREADY EMPLOYING THEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE
SHOULD ALLOW THEM TO DO SO AND
BEGIN THE REAL IT. MANY SCHOOLS
OF ART OF YEP AND I THINK WE
COULD HAVE RE OPENED OUR
SCHOOLS. TWO MONTHS AGO. WE
COULD HAVE BEEN HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS MONTHS AGO WE
SHOULD TO COME TO A TO. A
DETERMINATION MONTHS AGO TO DO
THIS I RECOGNIZE A LOT OF AS WE
CAN BEEN BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR.
REFUSES TO MOVE. YEAH FROM HIS
OWN POSITION FROM AN ARBITRARY
WAY OF DOING THIS. THIS
RESULTED IN OUR STUDENTS
LANGUISHING. AT HOME AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO HAVE IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND OUR PARENTS ARE
FRUSTRATED AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
SO THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE
AND I AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO SEE US MAKE THOSE CHANGES TO
ENSURE THIS IS EQUAL ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE. DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS IN
DIFFERENT AREAS AND EVEN IN THE
SAME COUNTIES WHERE ONE SCHOOL
IS ABLE TO DO THIS BUT ANOTHER
SCHOOL HAS TO DO SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT. I DON'T
WANT TO CREATE THAT KIND OF
SITUATION. THANK YOU DR WORK.
YES I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THIS
DISCUSSION A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT I HAD WALKING IN HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED- HOWEVER I DO HAVE
SOME SOME THAT THAT DO LINGER-
A FIRST OF ALL HI. MY DISTRICT.
I HAVE LIKE OVER EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS EIGHT ZERO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. MANY OF THEM ARE
TINY AND WHAT I HEAR FROM THE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS- DISTRICTS THE SCHOOLS
IN THE FIVE COUNTIES I
REPRESENT IS THAT THAT LARGE
LARGER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
URBAN AREAS ARE THE ONES ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO RE OPEN THE
ONES THAT ARE OUT IN THE MORE
RURAL AREAS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO RE OPEN. AND PART OF
THE CONCERN IS AROUND THE
CADENCE FOR TESTING. AND THE
CHALLENGE OF GATHERING THE
TESTS AND EVEN GETTING THEM TO
BE PROCESSED IN A TIMELY WAY-
EVEN IN UNDER A HYBRID LEARNING
SYSTEM IS GOING TO BE A
DIFFICULT. LET ME GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW DIFFICULT THAT
MIGHT BE IN DEL NORTE COUNTY
RIGHT NOW- FOR THIS NORTH
COUNTY NORTHWEST COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU CAN'T GET FROM
NORTH TO SOUTH ON ANY GIVEN DAY
BECAUSE THE ROADS CLOSED. WOULD
HAVE LANDSLIDES FOR THE LAST
WEEK SEVERAL WEEKS. YOU
COULDN'T GET A TESTING YOU CAN
GET TRANSPORTED IF YOU DOUBT IF
YOU WANTED TO YOU DID MAYBE YOU
COULD FLY IT OUT. SO THAT
DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T- EXACTLY-
DO ANYTHING TO LOWER THE COSTS
FOR THAT. AND SO- SO THERE'S
THERE WE CERTAINLY HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THAT AND THE
DISPARITY. AND THEN WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO THE CADENCE
TESTING- THE ENORMOUS COSTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THEY'RE GONNA RUN OUT OF MONEY
FOR THAT- IN NOT TO IN THE NOT
TOO DISTANT FUTURE SHOULD THEY
HAVE TO UNDERGO SOME OF THE KEY
THE TESTING CADENCE THAT'S
THAT'S GOING TO BE REQUIRED-
APPRECIATE WHAT I DID. I'VE HAD
PARRAMATTA CONFUSION- BUT IT IT
CLEAR FROM NOW BUT THERE WAS A
LOT OF CONFUSION ABOUT. AND NEW
M. O. USE. THAT MIGHT HAVE TO
BE DONE- WHICH DOESN'T APPEAR
TO BE HAPPENING AND SO THAT'S
THAT'S HELPFUL- THERE'S CONCERN
THAT VACCINES WOULD BE
REQUIRED- EVERYBODY WOULD HAVE
TO BE REQUIRED TO BE VACCINATED
AND THAT DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE
THE CASE SO THERE'S A LOT OF
CLARITY THAT'S COME OUT OF THIS
TODAY. BUT IT JUST GOES TO SHOW
HOW CHALLENGING THIS CAN BE.
ONE AREA THAT IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE FOR US. AND WE TALKED
ABOUT PARA PROFESSIONALS- YES
THERE MAY INDEED HAVE BEEN PARA
PROFESSIONALS THAT WERE LAID
OFF IN A LOT OF DISTRICTS. BUT
ON ANY GIVEN DAY IN A LOT OF MY
DISTRICT THEY COULDN'T HIRE
PREPARE PROFESSIONAL. IF THEY
WANTED TO BECAUSE THEY DON'T
EXIST. THEY DON'T EXIST YOU
CAN'T GET THE STAFFING THAT YOU
NEED. AND YET IT'S GOING TO BE
REQUIRED MY UNDERSTANDING UNDER
THE LEARNING LOST PART OF THIS
BILL THESE BILL. IT'S GOING TO
BE REQUIRED SO IF YOU IF YOU
DON'T HAVE PEOPLE TO HIRE HOW
DO YOU HIRE THEM WHAT DO YOU DO
IN THOSE IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND DOES THAT
MEAN THAT THAT ARE DISTRICTS
FURTHER LOSE OUT- SO I'D LOVE
TO KNOW. IF YOU CAN'T HIRE PARA
PROFESSIONALS. ARE WE GOING TO
JUST BE MORE DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED IN ART AND SOME
ARE RURAL AREAS SO THAT'S
THAT'S MY QUESTION. SO THE
LANGUAGE IS THE BILL AS YOU
SAID DOES REQUIRE THE 10% OF
EACH ELLIE AS LEARNING LOSS
FUNDS BE UTILIZED FOR THESE
PERFECTION ALL'S. AND OBVIOUSLY
WE DON'T AND SAY EXACTLY WHICH
TYPES OF SERVICES AS PER
PROFESSIONALS WOULD BE
PROVIDING- BUT IN THIS SCENARIO
YOU DESCRIBE IF AND ONLY A-
COULD NOT FIND ANY PARA
PROFESSIONALS TO HIRE OVER THE-
COURSE OF THE GRANTCHESTER
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THEN PRESUMABLY THEY WOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO SPEND A PORTION
OF THEIR FUNDS. UNDER THE WAY
THE BILL CERTAINLY WRITTEN SO
THAT WOULD BE A
DISPROPORTIONAL. DISSIPATE
DISADVANTAGE TO IN A RURAL AREA
SIMPLY COULDN'T FIND THAT
STAFFING BECAUSE. IT DOESN'T
EXIST IN SOME OF THESE AREAS.
SO WHAT I'M ASKING FOR IS IF IT
COULD BE DEMONSTRATED THAT IT'S
THAT THAT THAT JUST CAN'T
HAPPEN OR WON'T HAPPEN.
FLEXIBILITY THE ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH TO ALL THE THINGS
WE DO IN THIS BUILDING. REALLY
REALLY DISPROPORTIONATELY
DISADVANTAGED RURAL COMMUNITIES
THEY REALLY DO ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND YOU CAN TAKE THESE THINGS
THESE KINDS A DISPROPORTIONATE
THE DISADVANTAGING AND YOU CAN
TRANSLATE THAT TO URBAN CENTERS
AS WELL. UNDER SERVICED URBAN
CENTERS LIKE IN LOSE IN AND
MISSED RIVAS IS DISTRICT AND IN
MANY OTHER MEMBERS DISTRICTS IN
HERE. SO IT'S IT IS IT FEELS IN
MANY WAYS THAT. THE RICH GET
RICHER. AND THOSE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE. YOU CAN YOU CAN EVEN
ADD INTERNET ACCESS TO THAT TOO
BECAUSE I KNOW IN SOME OF HER
AREAS AND SOME OF THE OTHER
OTHER MEMBERS IN HERE IN LARGER
URBAN AREAS THEY DON'T HAVE
INTERNET ACCESS EITHER AND THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO WORK ON
THAT DISTANCE LEARNING PART OF
IT. SO WE NEED FLEXIBILITY. AND
ALSO RECOGNITION THAT LIFE IS
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE AND THAT'S OFTEN
WHAT'S MISSING FROM OUR
CONVERSATIONS. I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY JUST BASING YOUR
COMMENTS DR WOULD SO AGAIN IT'S
ONLY A TEN PERCENT- IT'S ONLY
10% SET ASIDE- THE RESOURCES
ARE MEANT FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SO THIS IS. FOR
BILLION ON TOP OF WHAT THEY
WOULD NORMALLY GET THROUGH L.
C. F. F. SO IN A SENSE WE
BELIEVE IT'S MUCH EASIER IF
THEY ARE GOING TO GET
ADDITIONAL THIS IS ADDITIONAL
IN PERSON. IS NOT MEANT TO BE
FOR A INTERNET COMPANY- LET ME
LET ME JUST FINISH AND THEN YOU
CAN MAKE A COMMENT. SO AGAIN-
WE THOUGHT IT WAS A FAIR SET
ASIDE BECAUSE IT'S MUCH EASIER
FRANKLY. TO GET- PERRIS HIRED
THEN TEACHERS HIGHER AND SO. IF
YOU'RE GOING TO BE DOING IN
PERSON EDUCATION THOSE ARE
REALLY YOUR- BRITISH FORCES A
LETTER TELLING ME IN YOUR
COMMUNITY. YES I THINK IT'S
HIGH TEACHER THAT WE CAN A
DIFFERENT THIS CALL IS NOT EASY
TO HIRE TEACHERS EITHER I MEAN
YOU KNOW YOU COULD YOU COULD
SAY THE SO YOU HIGHER PARRIS
THROUGH AND YOU'RE GOING TO DO
THROUGH TO- DISTANCE LEARNING.
IT DOESN'T WORK IN A LOT OF
AREAS BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING. SO YOU CAN EVEN HIRE
THE PEOPLE. TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE BECAUSE IF YOU HIRE THE%
PEOPLE THEY COULDN'T GET TO THE
PEOPLE THAT NEED IT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT BUT BUT AGAIN THIS IS SAM.
THIS IS FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES SO I KNOW THIS COULD
BE CONTEMPLATED FOR SUMMER
SCHOOL SO YOU COULD HAVE THE
SAME PARENTS WERE WORKING FOR
YOU FOR THE SCHOOL YEAR.
TEACHERS SUMMER SCHOOL. YOU
COULD HAVE. THE SAME PARENTS
WERE WORKING FOR YOU DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR- BE PART. OF THE
SUMMER THE FOLLOWING YEAR OR
AFTER SCHOOL SO THIS IS NOT.
SAYING YOU HAVE TO GO HIRE
ANYBODY JUST GIVES YOU.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ON TOP OF
YOUR NORMAL. SCHOOL DAYS COULD
BE SUMMER. COULD BE AFTER
SCHOOL BEFORE SCHOOL. THIS IS
MEANT TO BE ON TOP OF ALREADY
WHICH AGAIN FOR ELSE SILVA. AND
I AND I PRAY AND I APPRECIATE
THAT I WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO USE.
YOU KNOW. TECHNOLOGY FOR SOME
OF THE PARA PROFESSIONAL.
DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S WINTER
OR SUMMER. WE DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO IT EITHER.
SO WE'RE WE'RE NOT USING
TECHNOLOGY THE WHOLE POINT OF.
THE WAY THAT THIS PROPOSALS
WRITTEN IT'S MEANT TO BE IN
PERSON WE'VE SEEN. WELL WHAT
DISTANCE LEARNING DOES. AND SO
WE ARE RICH. THE ABILITY TO
DISTANCE LEARN IT IS MEANT FOR
IN PERSON THE MAJORITY LARGE
MAJORITY OF IT IS MEANT FOR. IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. IT AGAIN
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR AROUND IN PERSON.
CONSTRUCTION WORK YOU KNOW
THAT'S NEVER BEEN A DEBATE.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE COLDER THAT
WE ALLOWED. TO HAVE DISTANCE
LEARNING BUT IF IT WERE NOT
COLD AND WE WERE WITH HIM THERE
WAS NO INTEREST IN REVISITING-
IN PERSON WE ALL WE ALL BELIEVE
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION THAT'S
WHAT THE PARENTS BELIEVE THAT
TEACHERS BELIEVE THE TO THE
SUPERINTENDENTS BELIEVE WE ALL
BELIEVE IN THAT SO- THAT THAT'S
THIS MONIES. IS GO BACK TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. BUT I GUESS
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT. WINTER
SPRINGS FALL WE STILL HAVE
DIFFICULT HIRING. OF MATTER
SEASON IS AND DOESN'T. IT'S
STILL A CHALLENGE AND SOME OF
OUR DISTRICTS. THANK YOU- MRS-
AND THEN DISTRICT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. AND I WANT TO SAY
ALSO THANK YOU TO ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE- BROUGHT UP
A VERY LIVELY DISCUSSION ON THE
ISSUES OF SCHOOL RE OPENING
IDEA I HAD SOME QUESTIONS AND
FOR NOW WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS
FOCUS ON. SB NINETY FOUR- ON
THE- SMALL BUSINESS LICENSING
FEE. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
IF I CAN GET ADDRESSED. MISTER
TRAILER FROM YOU OR YOUR STAFF
OR ANYONE- FROM THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT LISTEN AGAIN. ON
SECTION TO BE FOR. SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT SHALL NOT REFUND ANY
LICENSE RENEWAL FEES PAID
BEFORE. THE ENACTMENT OF THIS
SECTION OR THE SUBMISSION OF A
WAIVER. REQUEST BY A LICENSEE.
SO COUPLE OF QUESTIONS WHY IS
THIS LANGUAGE PROHIBITING THE
DEPARTMENT FROM ISSUING
RETROACTIVE RELIEF FOR. STRIDES
THAT WERE CLOSED BY THE STATE
FOR MOST OF LAST YEAR- AND TO
WOULD BE FOR PROHIBIT
RESTAURANTS- INCLUDING MANY
THAT WERE YOUR PERMANENTLY
CLOSED DUE TO THE PANDEMIC FROM
SEEKING REFUNDS FOR THE FEES
PAID IN TWENTY TWENTY. I'D LIKE
TO HAVE CLARIFICATION- ABOUT
THIS AND- WHAT D. OR WHAT THE
INTENT IS BECAUSE IT DUE TO THE
CLASS ACTION LAWSUITS PENDING
ON THIS ISSUE WITH THIS
LANGUAGE DISRUPT SOME OF THESE
CLAIMS AS WELL. IF YOU CAN
CLARIFY THAT FOR ME I'D VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT. SURE THIS
IS ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND- AT THAT THAT
SECTION IS REALLY JUST TO SAY
THAT AND- WE WILL BE ISSUING
REFUNDS IF HE'S HAD ALREADY
BEEN PAID BUT THAT GOING
PROSPECTIVELY. THE FOLLOWING
YEAR- A WAIVER COULD BE
PROVIDED- IT SHOULD NOT
INTERRUPT ANY KIND OF
LITIGATION. THAT WHAT YOUR
QUESTION. SO SUCH A WHAT ABOUT
FOR PREVIOUS YEAR. THE PAIN FOR
LIFE LIFE PAID LESS YEAR WHEN
MORE THAN NINE MONTHS OF THE
YEAR MANY BUSINESSES WERE SHUT
DOWN WHAT HAPPENS THEN. CAN
THEY GET- A CREDIT TOWARDS A
FUTURE YEAR. THAT THE DOESN'T
REALLY ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. SURE
I'M AND ANY OF THE WAIVERS
WOULD ACTUALLY BEGIN MARCH
FIRST OF THIS YEAR AND SO THOSE
THAT WERE PAID IN THE PRIOR
YEAR CRACKED WILL NOT BE
REFUNDED- I WILL TURN THIS
QUESTION OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
AMY TRAVESTY SHE HAS ANY
FURTHER DETAILS PROVIDE THANK
YOU. IN THE SERVICE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING HAVE ANYTHING TO IT
IS TAX BUT- CLARIFY THE- IS
MAKE IT. THAT WE ARE NOT ABLE
TO ISSUE REFUNDS FROM THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL I'M
AND THAT IS PARTIALLY BECAUSE
OF IT SYSTEMS NOT BEING ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT. AS WELL AS
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW YOU TRACK
AND MONITOR ALL OF THAT SO
PERSPECTIVE LEE WAS THE
APPROACH WE CHOSE TO TAKE IN
THE SITUATION. SO MISTER TERRY
DO YOU MIND IF I CONTINUE WITH
THANK YOU. UP SO THEN TELL ME
IF YOU DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF.
HOW MANY DOLLARS WERE COLLECTED
BY. RESTAURANTS FOR EXAMPLE AND
I RAISE THIS ISSUE BECAUSE AS
AS IMPORTANT AS THE EDUCATION
PIECE HAS BEEN. RIGHTLY MOST OF
THE CONVERSATION HAS BEEN ON
THAT FRONT. I REPRESENT ALONG
WITH SOME OF US HERE AT EIGHT
EIGHT PART OF CALIFORNIA THAT.
IS VERY MUCH ORIENTED IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY AND IS
HEAVILY IMPACTED. WHEN
ESPECIALLY A LOT OF THESE
RESTAURANTS. CATER TO THE
INDUSTRY- HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN-
AND- IN GENERAL JUST. A PART OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THAT PROVIDES A
AND FOOD AND RESTAURANTS. ARE A
BIG PART OF THE ENTERTAINMENT-
IS I'M I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
FOR THESE BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING AND- IT'S ONE
THING FOR PROSPECTIVELY TO
ADDRESS THIS BUT- CAN WE- HAVE
WE DONE ENOUGH. TO RESEARCH TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT EXACTLY HOW
MUCH IS THE AMOUNT. THAT FOR
LAST YEAR THESE BUSINESSES WERE
SETBACK. FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
DO WE HAVE A NUMBER. AND THE
END JUST FOR CLARIFICATION I
DON'T COULDN'T SPEAK TO THE
ACTUAL REVENUE THAT THOSE AT
RESTAURANTS LOST IN TERMS OF.
HOW MUCH REVENUE THEY LOST AS A
RESULT NO I'M SORRY I GUESS I
DIDN'T ASK IT. SIMPLY ENOUGH
WHAT IS THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
GENERATED BY THE STATE BY THESE
LICENSES. FOR LAST YEAR. IT'S
ROUGHLY FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OKAY. AND IF
WE HAVE A RECORD OF WHO'S PAID.
I UNDERSTAND THE TIMING OF IT
ME. GIVEN THE- CONTINUOUS
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE WHEN IT
COMES TO I. T. I CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT WE MAY NEED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS. BUT WHY
NOT AT LEAST LOOK AT. EVEN IF
IT'S NOT REFUNDING BY GIVING
THEM CREDIT TOWARDS SOME OF
THEM HAVE LOST THEIR BUSINESS
COMPLETELY MAY WANT TO PUT SOME
MONEY ASIDE AND FIGURE OUT
OPENING UP SOMETHING IN THE
NEXT TWO YEARS YOUR TO WHY NOT
GIVE THOSE BUSINESSES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A CREDIT.
TO NOT. INCUR AN ADDITIONAL
COST- FOR ALL FOR ALL THE BRICK
AND MORTAR COST THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH WHEN
SETTING UP A NEW BUSINESS. SO
I'M I'M I'M ASKING THAT FOR
BOTH BUSINESSES WERE PERSONALLY
SHUT DOWN BUT ALSO BUSINESSES
THAT STRUGGLING BY NOW AND
LITTLE BIT OF AN INJECTION
MONEY. OR CREDIT TOWARDS A
FUTURE YEAR WOULD WOULD GO A
LONG WAY. AND WHAT I DO THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WE HADN'T WITH ALLEGE OF WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE AGREED TO
PROVIDING TWO YEARS OF REALLY
FOR THESE BUSINESSES RATHER
THAN JUST THE ONE THAT WE HAD A
PROPOSED IN JANUARY- SO THAT IS
ONE ELEMENT RIVER TRYING TO
ADDRESS IT. I'M I ALSO THERE'S
STOP RESOURCES AND COSTS TO THE
STATE ALSO OF REFUNDING THOSE.
THOSE I FEES THAT WERE PAID
PREVIOUSLY BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY WERE REALLY JUST TRYING
TO PROVIDE PERSPECTIVE REALLY
FOR THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
STILL IN OPERATION I'M SORRY
RECOGNIZE. THE SERVICE LET ME
LET ME INTERRUPT YOU I DON'T%
FIND THAT ARGUMENT BEING. VERY
THE BEST ARGUMENT TO USE THAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE STAFF TIME
TO REFINE FOLKS. THAT HAVE
BEEN- THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
BY THIS I DON'T I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES. FIND THAT TO BE A
VERY GOOD ARGUMENT I DON'T-
EXPECT. FACT ME READ THIS AGAIN
THE- SHALL NOW. REFUND ANY
LICENSE RENEWAL FEES PAID
BEFORE THE IT NACHMAN OF THIS
SECTION. SO THEN FOLKS THAT
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE PAID THIS
FEE. FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE
YEAR BUT WEREONLY ABLE TO
OPERATE FOR TWO AND A HALF
MONTHS OF THAT YEAR ARE NOT
GOING TO SEE ANY BENEFIT FOR
THE REMAINING NINE AND A HALF
MONTHS. OF THE FEE THAT WAS
PAID. SO I'M ASKING CAN WE HAVE
THIS. SECTION CHANGED. EVEN IN
A CUT IN THE FUTURE BILL IN A
IN A IN A FUTURE TRAILER BILL.
OR OR OR MAYBE EVEN OFF ON
THIS. TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN.
GIVE APPROPRIATE CREDIT BACK TO
BUSINESSES FOR LAST YEAR. NOT
FROM THE TIME OF THE ENACTMENT
OF THIS BEFORE LAST YEAR. HI
THIS IS DIRECTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AGAIN
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL WAS FOR A
SINGLE YEAR ANDREW NEGOTIATIONS
WE HAVE EXTENDED IT TO TWO
YEARS BUT I ALSO WANT TO POINT
TWO OTHER. PROPOSALS WITHIN
THIS PACKAGE WHICH HELP TO
ADDRESS THE THOSE SAME SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING IN REGARDS TO GRANT
DOLLARS- AND TAXI RELIEF SO AS
A PACKAGE THERE ARE MULTIPLE
PROPOSALS THAT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HELP MANY IN SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING. OKAY WELL I GUESS
I'VE MADE MY POINT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR AT THIS POINT. IT'S GOING
TO BE SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GONNA WAIT AND SEE AND LOOK AT
HOW. THIS EXACTLY ADDRESSES THE
NEEDS OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THERE'S
AMBIGUITY AND NOT CLEAR- WHAT
WHAT GOOD QUESTION ALSO THAT
WAS NOT REALLY ANSWERED WAS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'LL THIS
LANGUAGE. IS GOING TO IN ANY
WAY IMPACT THE CLASS ACTION
WITH THE- WITH THE LAWSUITS
THAT ARE PENDING RIGHT NOW.
DOES IT DO THAT. HI ERIC LEAGUE
AND- NO THIS THIS LANGUAGE IS
NOT. INTENDED AT ALL TO
INTERFERE WITH THOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
MR WITH THE MISTER MATHIS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUGGEST
TAKING MEMBERS WERE VERY ROBUST
DIALOGUE ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
WE ARE VOTING ON. TODAY AS WELL
AS THE RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION I THINK IT WARRANTS
ARE. OUR INTERROGATION OF THE
PLANET WARRANTS ARE CRITICISMS
OR WARTS ARE- CRITIQUE OF THE
PLAN BECAUSE IF WE DO MOVE BACK
TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION IT
WILL BE A SINGLE MOST DRAMATIC
COVED ADAPTATION WE'VE HAD.
THIS WHOLE OVER TIME WE ARE
APPROACHING ONE YEAR OF THE
COVER TIMES AND AT LEAST THIS
COUNTRY AND IT'S IMPORTANT
MEMBER AS I HEAR A LOT OF GREAT
COMMENTS- REMEMBERING THAT
THERE IS A GREAT TRAUMA TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO OUR STUDENTS
RIGHT NOW. IS THAT THE VIRUS
THAT STILL RAGES IN THIS
COUNTRY. AT PERHAPS
EMBARRASSMENT TO THE DEBT THE
END TO THE ENTIRE DEVELOP THE
WORLD IN THIS COUNTRY. IS THE
CAUSE OF ALL OF THAT THAT IS
THE REASON WHY WE MUST REMAIN
VIGILANT ABOUT IT WHY WE HAVE
HYBRIDISE SUCTION WIFE TO
COURTS. AND MY FRANKLY LIKE
YOUNG PEOPLE MIGHT BE. IN THREE
MONTHS GRADUATING INTO AN
ECONOMY THAT HAS NO JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM THAT HAS
MADE SO THEY COULDN'T SEE THE
ELDER RELATIVES WHO PASSED
AWAY. AND PERHAPS EVEN LESS
OPPORTUNITY THAN EVEN THE
GENERATION MY GRADUATE
GENERATION HAD EVEN LESS THAN
THAT BEFORE. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT WHILE WE MUST
FIGHT FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
RETURN TO THAT SENSE OF
NORMALCY. IT WILL NOT SHORT.
UNTIL WE DEFEAT THE VIRUS IT
WILL NOT CURE ALL THOSE
ELEMENTS OF THOSE PROBLEMS ARE
EXISTING UNTIL WE- UNTIL WE
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESSED THE
VIRUS. AND ALL ITS IMPACTS
THAT'S WHY I'M REALLY GLAD
WE'RE VOTING TODAY AT LEAST ON
THE BIG PACKAGE OF STIMULUS.
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO WORKING
FAMILIES DIRECT PAYMENTS SMALL
BUSINESSES. ALTHOUGH IN THE
DISTRICT LIKE MINE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS JUST TO WORKING CLASS
FAMILY WILL EVAPORATE IN RENT.
PROBABLY IN HALF A MONTH AND
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS WILL
EVAPORATE IN COMMERCIAL RENT
AND LESS THAN THAT. WELL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT ONE TIME.
RELIEF IT'S STILL RELIEF BUT WE
NEED TO BE DOING HOPEFUL THE
FOUNDER OF. WILL BE HELD
HELPING US OUT. FOR FILLING
THEM NOW. WELL WE WAIT FOR
CONGRESS. TO APPROPRIATE WARM
DIRECT TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
NEED. AND THAT'S WHY LOWER VOTE
ON THE STATE'S WORKING- EARLY
ACTION. WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
IS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SCHOOL
RE OPENING AS I'VE EXPRESSED
BEFORE AS WE SHOULD NOT BE
MOTIVATED BY AN ARBITRARY
CALENDAR IN THE DAY. YES IT'S
THE END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR IS
COMING AND THE MORE TIME WE
WAIT THE MORE MORE TIME WILL BE
WASTED. BUT I'M REMINDED THAT
EVEN IN MY DISTRICT IN FREMONT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT LAST
WEEK THERE WAS A- SURVEY
RELEASED OF TEN THOUSAND
PARENTS AND 63% OF THEM SAID
THEY DID NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE.
PUTTING US IN A BACK IN IN
PERSON TRACTION THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S A CHOICE RATES AT LEAST
40% CAN HAVE THAT OPTION. BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE IT
A SAFE ENVIRONMENT. PUBLICLY
HEALTH SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR
STUDENTS OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
EDUCATORS OF COURSE. I'M AND OF
COURSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
FAIR CRITICISM I THINK OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT ITS ROLE
IN THE VACCINES. AND HOW THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR A PLANNED SINCE LAST
YEAR WHEN THIS VIRUS BEGAN.
WHAT WOULD THE PLAN BE WHAT
WOULD THE STATE WIDE STANDARD
B. AND I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
SO UNITED. THE UNITED THAT
UNITES THE GOVERNOR. THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP IN
MAKING SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN SAFELY AGAIN. SO I'M
WONDERING. COULD THIS IS A
QUESTION I THINK IT'S FOR OUR
COMMITTEE. COULD WE PUT IN THE
BILL. TO WELFARE AS A CIVIL OR
L. O. CON. ESTIMATE MORE
OBVIOUS THERE'S BEEN IN OTHER
OF A EQUITY IT AND SOMETIMES
ARBITRAGE. OF I'M CERTAIN TAG
OF AKI. BEING BONTA THE LIST
ARE BEING PUT ON THE- COULD WE
NOT SINCE WE HAVE. THE URGENCY
AND THE DRIVE TO MAKE SURE OUR
STUDENTS GET BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM. TO PRIORITIZE BYLAWS
A MANDATE. THAT OUR EDUCATORS
ARE TEACHERS OUR GENERAL STAFF
ARE CLASSIFIED STAFF. ARE
PRIORITIZE FOR THE VACCINE. IS
THAT SOMETHING WE COULD DO.
THAT'S ACOSTA. I GUESS THAT IS
ONE OF PROVISION OF SB SIX
CHANGE. THAT SCHOOL PER. WHO
ARE PROVIDE. SIR IN PERTH TO
STAY. REGARDLESS WHETHER THAT'S
ON CAMPUS. OR I'M IN A LEARNING
HUB OR YOUR FOOD DISTRIBUTION
SITE. THAT THEY WOULD RECEIVE
PRIORITY FOR VACCINE ACCESS
UNDER ONE B. OKAY THAT'S GOOD.
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU THOSE ARE
HABITS. THANK YOU MISTER MISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
MEMBERS OF IT WOULD BE
REELECTED OF ME NOT TO. DIVE
BACK INTO SOME OF THE POINTS
MADE BY- OUR COLLEAGUES MR
GALLAGHER AND MR WOODS IN
REGARDS TO THE RURAL. DISTRICT
ISSUES. MY COLLEAGUES ARRIVE
THERE'S A HUGE DISPARITY HERE.
AND WHAT REALLY CONCERNS ME IN
WHAT IS OFTEN MISSED. WHEN
DISCUSSING OUR SMALL RURAL
SCHOOLS IT IS THE FACT THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE ABILITIES TO DO
ALL OF THESE THINGS. SO WHAT
ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS THERE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE HERE FOR
THEM. AND WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE FOR THEM TO EVEN GET THAT.
YES THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
SO- IN ADDITION TO THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT THE-
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
ALREADY BROUGHT ONLINE SO THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HAS BROUGHT AT PEDIATRIC HEALTH
AND SCHOOL BASED SAFETY EXPERTS
ON BOARD AND ARE WORKING IN
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE THAT INTENSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AROUND.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PRACTICES
WHAT SB EIGHTY SIX DOES THEN IT
ASKS ATTY- ADDITIONAL- WAY OF
HAVING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THROUGH THE
REGIONAL LEADS ACROSS THE STATE
AROUND EDUCATIONAL PRACTICE IN
A TRAUMA. INFORMED ENVIRONMENT
SO HOW DO YOU ADDRESS LEARNING
LOSS AND THE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING OF STUDENTS IN A
COVERT ENVIRONMENT TO HELP
ADDRESS THEIR LEARNING LOSS IN
A WAY THAT IS BASED OFF THE
SCIENCE AND BASED OFF OF BEST
PRACTICES THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE NOT RECREATING THE WHEEL.
AND ISOLATION SO THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE UNDER SB EIGHTY SIX
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE. I
UNDERSTANDABLE BUT TO DOCTOR
WOODS POINT HI HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO GET OUT THERE. I HAVE
I HAVE AREAS IN MY DISTRICT.
THAT MY I'VE GOT SCHOOLS THAT
ARE TWO HOURS AWAY FROM COUNTY
CENTERS SUMMER THREE FOUR HOURS
AWAY. THEY DON'T HAVE. INTERNET
SERVICE THEIR FAMILIES DON'T
HAVE INTERNET SERVICE SO WHAT
IS THE ACTUAL PLAN. TO REACH
THE I HAVE AREAS THAT LIKE DR
WOODS. WHO ARE DEALING WITH.
MUDSLIDES LANDSLIDES SNOW IN
ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT IT OTHER
SITUATIONS. STILL RECOVERING
FROM WILDFIRES SITUATIONS. WHO
CANNOT BE REACHED EASILY THESE
ARE VERY ISOLATED COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE STRUGGLING AND NEED
HELP IN THEIR KIDS DESERVE TO
GO BACK TO SCHOOLS WHILE.
BECAUSE THE DISTANCE LEARNING
DOESN'T WORK FOR THEM BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT INTERNET
ACCESS. SO THEIR FAMILIES ARE
HAVING TO DRIVE. IN OUR TO A
SCHOOL TO GO PICK UP A PACKET
SO THEIR KIDS CAN LEARN IN
THERE DOING THIS. IN AND I KNOW
THIS FIRST HAND. I WENT TO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. IN A THREE
CLASSROOM SCHOOL THAT WAS K.
THROUGH SIX. OUR PRINCIPAL WAS
ALSO THE FIFTH AND SIXTH GRADE
TEACHER. WHO ALSO DID ALL THE
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK- ALSO DROVE
ONE OF THE BUS ROUTES. THESE
PEOPLE WEAR MULTIPLE HATS. AND
I KNOW A MAJORITY OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE WE
THEY'VE YET ANOTHER RIVER TO
LIVE DID OR NEVER EXPERIENCED
OR NEVER SEEN IT. THESE PEOPLE
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE THE TIME. OF
THE DAY. TO PUT ALL OF THESE
THINGS TOGETHER. TO DO THIS SO
TO SAY YES THERE'S GOING TO BE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT THAT
THAT'S GREAT TO SAY IT. BUT
WHO'S ACTUALLY GONNA SHOW UP
AND HELP THEM DO THIS. BECAUSE
THAT. IS AN EQUITY ISSUE.
BECAUSE THEY DESERVE IT TOO.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT IN HERE
WHICH IS WHY I'VE GOTTEN A
PHONE CALL THAT I'VE GOT AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THESE THESE
GIANT NASCAR. FIRELESS FROM ALL
OVER DIFFERENT SCHOOLS. OUR
PARENTS ONCE YOUR KIDS GO BACK.
I'M A PARENT I WANT TO SEE MY
KIDS GO BACK. BECAUSE WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WE CAN TALK ABOUT ALL OF
THE OTHER THINGS BUT WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES. IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY. SO IT'S FAIR
WHAT A LOT OF YOU CONSIDER
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND MY LARGER
CITIES. MOST OF MY SCHOOL-
LITTLE COUNTY IRELAND SCHOOLS.
SOME OF THEM STILL HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WATER. WE HAVE ALL
THESE ISSUES THEY STILL HAVEN'T
GONE AWAY. SO WE APPRECIATE THE
ISSUES WHAT YOUR RECOMMENDATION.
WE NEED WE DON'T WANT TO THE MR
CARE WE GOTTA GET ASSISTANCE
OUT THERE. BECAUSE WE CAN'T SIT
HERE AND SAY HEY WE'RE GONNA
THROW TWO BILLION DOLLARS AT IT.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO UP
HERE ALL THE TIME FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE. WE
THROW MONEY AT A PROBLEM WE
HAVE SOME GREAT TALKING POINTS
FOR SOME GREAT HEADLINES MISTER
CHAIR. BUT OUR PEOPLE IN OUR
RURAL AREAS STILL GET LEFT
BEHIND. AND WHAT ASSISTANCE ARE
YOU LOOKING FOR. DANNY THE HELP
THAT THAT'S TO GET THE DAILY IF
YOU HAVE TO COMMUNICATE THAT
YOU HAVE GIVE US JUST PHYSICS
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITY WE ARE
COMMITTED. YOU'VE HEARD OF
OTHER MEMBERS. KNOW WHAT I
HEARING IS. THE SYSTEM THE TO
WORK WE ALL A REAL SCHOOLS
ACROSS THE STATE SO US WHAT TO
DO. ABSOLUTE AND WHAT WE HEARD
FROM THE ON NASCAR IS. WE WANT
FLEXIBILITY THE GUY FLEXIBILITY
ASM. I THINK WE JUST FINISH MY
POINT WE ALREADY THE LETTER. I
GOT FIVE BILLION. COMPLETELY
FLEX AND DON'T HAVE SO OF. SO
THAT WORK. WE HAVE SOME SCHOOL
OPEN AS MR GAL SAID. AND THOSE
CLEAN TO SCALE AND THEN WE HE-
ALL WE CAN'T LET OTHER IN
PURPLE TEAR LET LIKE MY TESTER.
OPEN BECAUSE THERE'S A WRECK
SHOWING THEY CAN DO IT. ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS THAT OPEN OPEN
DURING TO. AND THEY DEVELOP
THAT OWN RECORD. SO WHY IS IT
WE LET HIM OPEN. OTHER TEARS.
ON A DIFFERENT- OF RULES IN
THIS IS PROBABLY KEEP CHANGING
THE RULES. CHAU UNTIL WE STOP
MESSING WITH WITH ALL THE RULES
WE ACTUALLY DID. FOLKS IN THERE
PHYSICALLY IN THERE THAT CAN
HELP. AND WORK THROUGH THESE
ISSUES AND SIT DOWN. WITH THE
FOLKS IN OUR RURAL AREAS IN IN
MAKE SURE THESE THINGS GET
PLANNED OUT CORRECTLY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE IN IN EQUITY WE'RE
GONNA HAVE PEOPLE GETTING LEFT
BEHIND. NOW I I'LL ALSO THE-
GONNA SWITCH GEARS HERE.
BECAUSE I WANT TO TALK TO WOOD
MISTER NAZARIAN SAID. IT AS FAR
AS WE'RE WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
REFUND ANY OF THESE BUSINESS
LICENSES AND ABC LICENSES
BECAUSE OUR COMPUTER SYSTEM
THEY THEY HAVE I. T. ISSUES.
THIS IS ANOTHER ISSUE I'VE
BROUGHT UP SINCE I GOT ELECTED.
I REMEMBER SAYING HEY HOW CAN
WE DON'T HAVE AN APP FOR THAT
HOW COME OUR- BUREAUCRACIES ARE
RUNNING ON ANCIENT COMPUTERS.
WHO CAN'T KEEP TRACK OF THANKS.
SO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. WHAT
ARE WE GONNA FIX. OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEMS IN THE STATE. AS AN
ADMINISTRATION WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO FIX THIS. BECAUSE WE
CAN GO INTO THE DMV WEBSITE
CRASHING. IN THE DISPARITIES
THERE. DON'T GET ME STARTED ON
ET DE. THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
WHEN WE DID THE VACCINE
ROLLOUTS. ARE TWO ONE ONE
SYSTEM. NOW. WE CAN'T EVEN GET
ABC LICENSES TO TRACK WHAT KIND
OF COMPUTERS DO WE HAVE A CLEAR
ANSWER FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
WHAT WHAT TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY
ARE WE USING. BECAUSE ALL I
EVER HERE'S WE HAVE THESE IT
ISSUES I. T. ISSUES I. T.
ISSUES. WHAT WHAT SYSTEMS ARE
YOU GUYS USING. ACTUALLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LET ME JUST. OFFER A LITTLE
CONTEXT- MANY OF THE SYSTEMS
THAT THE STATE USES FOR A LOT
OF VERY COMPLICATED PROGRAMS
WERE BUILT. TWENTY THIRTY YEARS
AGO- AND THERE THESE PROGRAMS
ARE VERY COMPLEX AND ANY TIME
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE- THE
SYSTEMS NEED TO BE RE
PROGRAMMED SO SIMPLY THAT TAKES
A LOT OF TIME- AND THEN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AND
PERSISTENCE AND PROVIDED- OF.
NEW WAYS IN WHICH DEPARTMENT
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
BUILDING THESE COMPUTER SYSTEMS
GOING FORWARD BUT THE CURRENT
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE MANY OF
THEM ARE VERY OLD AS YOU
MENTIONED THE SYSTEM I THINK
THE- ARE EXAMPLES- BUT IT WOULD
ALSO TURN TO SOME OF THE MORE
NIMBLE SYSTEMS. AND
APPLICATIONS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING OUT SUCH AS MY TURN AND
SAY SCHOOL SAFE SCHOOLS FOR ALL
HAN. EVEN THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN AT THE DEAN-
WEBSITE- DEMONSTRATE SOME OF
THE- THAT WE ARE TO. SO THEY-
PERSPECTIVE LEGAL IMPORT. THANK
YOU MAY MISTER CHAIR EIGHT IN
IN MEMBERS I THINK IS WE TRY TO
PULL THROUGH THESE COVERT SOME
WE NEED TO AT IT IS WE GETTING
OUR OUR JUNE BUDGET. IS WHAT
ARE GONNA DO FIX THESE TWENTY
YEAR OLD COMPUTER SYSTEMS. WHAT
WE'RE ALL WALKING AROUND WE
WE'VE GOT OUR- SMARTPHONES
WE'VE GOT OUR TABLETS. MAKE
SURE WE HAVE SOME OF THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY AT OUR FINGERTIPS.
THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE THE
SYSTEMS THAT THEY DEPEND ON.
THIRTY YEARS OLD. MENTIONED
THIS OVER THIS WHEN I FIRST GOT
IN. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY HERE WE ARE TWENTY ONE.
IN THE SYSTEM STILL HAVEN'T
BEEN TOUCHED. BECAUSE WHAT WE
HEAR IS IT'LL COST TOO MUCH
MONEY OF I REMEMBER THOSE
BUDGET CONVERSATIONS. I
REMEMBER BEING TOLD ALL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS. YOU'RE
JUST YOUNG MILLENNIAL GUY. EASY
NOT EVERYTHING IS A GO TO ENACT.
NOT ONE OF US CAN STAND HERE
AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT IF WE HAD
A BETTER SYSTEM. OUR PEOPLE
WOULDN'T BE GETTING SERVED
BETTER. WE WOULDN'T HAVE THESE
EDT MASSES WE WOULDN'T HAVE
DIEM BE SHUT DOWN WE WOULDN'T
HAVE ALL OF THESE THINGS WOULD
HAVE SYSTEMS THAT CAN ACTUALLY
TRACK. WHAT THE HELL'S GOING ON
AND SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS.
MEMBERS I'D A BACON PLEAD OF
YOU AS WE APPROACH JUNE WE FIX
THOSE COMPUTER SYSTEMS. SORRY
THANK YOU- WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO MR FONG. I THINK IT IS
FAIR- I APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DEBATE ON THE- THE IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF A REAL BRING OUR
SCHOOLS SO I JUST WANT TO
INSURE THAT EVERY MEMBER GOT A
CHANCE TO- TO COMMENT AND ASK
QUESTIONS I DO WANT TO JUMP TO
SOME OTHER- THE OTHER BILLS ON
THE- FILE. SO IF I COULD ASK
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON SB
EIGHTY EIGHT- CERTAINLY THAT
THIS BODY HAS BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN HAVE REGARDING THE-
THE FAILURES OF THE EDT. AND I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE
ANOTHER PROGRAM THAT PROMISES
TO HELP THOSE STRUGGLING DURING
THE PANDEMIC ONLY TO BEING WITH
WITH INEFFICIENCIES OF FRAUD SO
WHAT PROVISIONS AND SAFEGUARDS
ARE INCLUDED IN THIS BILL. TO
ENSURE PAYMENTS AND REALLY FOR
SENT TO THE APPROPRIATE
RECIPIENTS AND WHAT A FOUR CENT.
CAN BE GUARANTEED. YEAH
CERTAINLY WITH A DIFFERENT OF
FINANCE- POPULATIONS WHICH-
WILL BE INTEREST. OF THE- A
BOTH. FOR THE EITC ACTC. WILL
WELL ACTUALLY HAVE- TAX FILES.
THEN TO THOSE PAYMENTS WILL GO
OUT AND SELL THEM. YOUR TAX ARE
RECEIVED THERE'S- DEFINITELY A
DIFFERENT DEGREE OF VALIDATION.
FOR THAT AND IT SEEMS- BECAUSE
WORKS A SIGN. HE POPULATE THE
ARE NOT- DOES ALREADY KNOWN. SO
IT'S DIFFERENT FROM THE YOU
WANT THAT YOU UP OKAY. SO WE'VE
LEARNED A LESSON THAT THE BEEN
AND IT'S GONNA BE FROM MADEIRA
POSIT SOME AND THERE ISN'T A TO
BE THE SAME. SEN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS WILL BE
PROVIDED I BELIEVE THROUGH- ETT-
FOR THE CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
CURRENTLY DISCUSSING FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- ASSIST. SOME. OKAY
THANK YOU THIS IS IN A THAT THE
THAT THE FULL LENGTH WOULD BE
CONCERNED IF SO IF ANY
INFORMATION OF AS AS THAT HAS
THE OZZY LONG AS A CONTINUE
WOULD BE A APPRECIATED- IT'S
JUMPING TO S. B. EIGHTY FIVE.
CERTAINLY THERE'S A OF CONTRA
AND ON WHAT WE NOW AND- THE
LACK OF THE AUTHORITY THE
SECTOR STATE'S OFFICE HAD- FROM
I JUST. ON THIS CONTRACT WITH-
THE POLITICAL FIRM- SKG K. FOR
VOTER OUTREACH WHICH-
UNFORTUNATELY I WILL USE THE
FUNDS TO FOR PARTISAN PURPOSES-
HOW DOES THIS BILL CLARIFY- THE
LEGAL QUESTION THAT DOES THAT
WE GOT WE GOT INPUT FROM THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- HAD- AND
IN TERMS OF. HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THE NON COMPLIANCE WITH THE
PUBLIC CONTACT. SURE ACTUALLY
THE FINE- THE AMENDMENT IS
THERE IS CAR FINANCE. IN NATURE
IT DOESN'T THAT THIS OF STATE
HOUSING FOR ACCORDING TO EIGHT
WHAT WE DO TO BE ON THE CALL.
FOR SERVICE THAT HAVE BEEN-
PROVIDED TO THIS- SO WE IT'S A
TECHNO THIRTY DAY ON- A PRIOR.
ALLOCATION A NOW IN A PART.
OKAY SO IT IS BUT IT IS. THAT
WITH THE REASON WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS GRAPHIC WAS THAT. THE
PREVIOUS. AT THE WASN'T ATTIC.
I THINK THERE WAS CONCERN
COMING FROM THE CONTROLLER THE
STATE CAN AND THAT WE ADDRESS
THROUGH THE LANGUAGE YES-
CERTAINLY THIS IS A CAN.
PROVISION JUST BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF. HI- OVER STATEWIDE
FROM THE FROM FROM THE PREVIOUS
YEAR BUT- IS THERE ANY TIME OF.
A OR OVERSIGHT SOBRE TO ENSURE
THAT IN THE FUTURE THAT THE
TYPE OF STATE FUNDING ISN'T TO
BE USE FOR. POLITICAL ACTIVITY
OR PARTISAN ACTIVITY. YEAH I
I'LL I'LL TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE
OF NW JERSEY FOR MORE DETAILS
ON THE ACTUAL- EXPENDITURE IN
ORDER WITH THE TIME. SO ANY
JERVIS FROM FINANCE FUNDS. AND
YOU KNEW IN THAT THEY IN
RESPONSE TO. THE STATE FOR
VOTER EDUCATION OUTREACH AS A
RESULT OF CORONAVIRUS MAKING
SURE THAT THEY'RE WHAT THE
VOTERS HAD COMFORT IN OUR
ELECTION PROCESS AND CAME OUT
AND VOTED AND SO WE DON'T
ANTICIPATE THIS BEING AN ISSUE.
AND WHEN WE ORIGINALLY WORKED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
SEPARATION- WELL WE STATED THAT
THE FUNDS WERE FOR COUNTIES THE
AND ULTIMATELY WHAT THE STATE
SECRETARY OF STATE DID SORRY
WITH- AND ENTER INTO A
STATEWIDE CONTRACTS- FOR VOTER
EDUCATION OUTREACH PROVIDE A
CONSISTENT MESSAGE. STATEWIDE
IT DID RESULT IN THE HIGHEST
TURNOUT VOTER TURNOUT SINCE
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO WITH
SEVENTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
VOTERS OR NEARLY 71% OF ALL
ELIGIBLE REGISTERED. VOTERS
PARTICIPATING IN THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION. OKAY I MEAN I THE
CHALLENGES THAT HIS IS YOUR THE
WAS THERE YOU OF A STATE OF
MONEY. TO GET OUT THE VOTE AND
I THINK THAT CREE A LOT OF-
BANKS AND- FRUSTRATION AND THE
APPROPRIATENESS OF THIS TYPE
OF- FUNDS SO OF. I APPRECIATE
THE ANSWERS I KNOW THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY TROUBLING
TO MYSELF AND SOME OTHER
MEMBERS SO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT- FOR THE ANSWERS IN THE
GANDER- IN TERMS OF JUST
JUMPING OVER MY LAST COMMENT
AND JUMPING BACK INTO THE
SCHOOL DISCUSSION- I DO JUST
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE. THAT MR
VICE TRIES TO HAVE MY QUESTIONS
THE GO SO IF YOU'RE AFTER I AND
I'D SIT AND INDIFFERENCE THE
CHAIR TERMS OF HIS QUESTIONS I
DO WANT TO JUST A- LET THE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO AND
THE BUDGET. KNOW THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE DOZENS OF SAFETY
WAIVERS AND SAFETY. BUT WE
OPENING PLANS. THERE GONNA BE
SUBMITTED. AND THAT IS ALLOWS.
TO RE. AS SOON AS- AND IF
WAIVERS ARE NOT APPROVE. THEN
WE NOW. ARE IN JEOPARDY OF
DELAYING THE WOOD SCHOOL RE
OPENINGS- POSSIBLY. EVEN MORE
AND SO. THIS MAY NOT BE IT'S A-
SEPARATE FROM THIS DISCUSSION
BUT IT'S RELATED BECAUSE IF
THOSE WAIVERS ARE REJECTED. IN
SOME FORM OR FASHION- THEN WE
NOW HAVE CREATED A PROCESS
THAT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO RE OPEN AND THAT IS.
CERTAINLY MY CONCERN- SPEAKING
FOR A LOT OF THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES SO THANK YOU AGAIN.
AND I APPRECIATE MR JOBS ARE
BACK OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR I WAS JUST TO
GO BACK TO ALL- DISK. ON SB
EIGHT SAID- JUST GO TO GO BACK
TO HIS HOME AND ASK QUESTIONS
REGARDING ARE. YOU INTIMATED
ABOUT YOUR PROPOSAL- AND ON
MARCH- THE DEADLINE SO IF YOU
JUST. I WHICH WHICH TO ME-
THANK UP WITH MADRE REGIONAL
LET'S JUST OF AB TEN. WELL BUT
IF YOU COULD JUST KIND OF GO
THROUGH WHAT THE MARCH
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE WAS. YES THE
HOME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
BELIEVE ARE I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT WE'VE UPDATED OUR PROPOSAL
THAT WE PROVIDED PUBLICLY. AND
THAT HAD THAT FEBRUARY LANGUAGE
IN FEBRUARY DATE CERTAINLY
WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE- AND YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT. AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE'RE ALMOST ALL THE
WAY THROUGH FEBRUARY AT THI
POINT- THAT THAT WOULD
DEFINITELY PUSH THAT DATE BACK
BUT- YOU DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE.
FILTER PROPOSAL- POSTED BY AT
THIS TIME. OKAY BECAUSE YOU
WERE GUESS YOU WERE SPEAKING
ABOUT- ARE. ALSO THAT THIS
POINT THIS IS THE ONLY THING
YOU'RE COMMENTING ON IS YOUR
YOUR PUBLIC PROPOSAL- I BELIEVE
THE END OF DECEMBER IS THAT
CORRECT. YES OKAY VERY GOOD I
THOUGHT OF I DECIDED THAT I
WON'T GO FURTHER. REFERS INTO
THAT. I WOULD JUST URGE KNOW
WHAT WHAT I JUST. AND THEN JUST
TO GO INTO- YOU KNOW FINISHING
UP AND JUST WRAPPING UP I JUST
I JUST WANNA THANK EVERYBODY
FOR THE VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION.
ON WHAT I WOULD SAY IS. HAVING
NOW BEEN WORKING ON THIS
OPENING SCHOOLS ISSUE SINCE.
NOVEMBER I THINK IT IS A LITTLE
BIT IRONIC WHEN I HAVE
DISTRICTS. ASKING FOR
FLEXIBILITY I CAN THINK OF NO
MORE REGULATED- SUBJECT MATTER
THAN THE EDUCATION FIELD. DOWN
TO THE HOUR IS DOWN TO THE
CURRICULA AND DOWN TO THE
COURSES DOWN TO THE GRAZED DOWN
TO THE AGES. FRANKLY DOWN TO
THE ATTENDANCE AGAIN JUST
REMINDER ATTENDANCE IN SCHOOL
IS NOT FLEXIBLE- THERE'S ALMOST
NOTHING THAT IS FLEXIBLE. IN
EDUCATION- WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN
THE PAST WAS MOVE TOWARD OUR
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO GIVE DISTRICTS
ARE GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN TO A
LARGE EXTENT IT HAS WORKED.
VOCAL FLEXIBILITY. IN TERMS OF
ENSURING THAT LOCAL ISTRICTS.
COULD ADAPT TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT TO THEIR STUDENTS
OVERALL I BELIEVE WAS THE RIGHT
DECISION. WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
THAT. IN A PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC THAT HAS TOUCHED EVERY
SINGLE CORNER OF THE STATE- NOT
EQUALLY BUT AS DEFTLY TOUCHED
EVERY SINGLE CORNER OF THE
STATE. IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
OVER A THOUSAND DISTRICTS TO
COME UP WITH A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS. AND WHAT
WE HAD HOPED IS WHEN WE DID
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. IS BY
REALLY REALLY FORCEFULLY
ENCOURAGING EVERYBODY TO BE.
MOVING TO IN PERSON LEARNING
WHAT IT WAS POSSIBLE- AND AS WE
SAW CASE RATES REALLY DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE FALL AND
SCHOOLS STARTED. WE
UNFORTUNATELY DIDN'T SEE
DISTRICTS REALLY PREPARE FOR
OPENING UP SCHOOLS WHICH WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE BEST TIME. OF MY
COUNTY HAD ONE OF THE LOWEST
CASE RATES IN THE STATE WE
ACTUALLY REACHED. THE- SORT OF
ON IT DOUBLE YELLOW TIER
HOWEVER. NOTE AROUND SCHOOL
REAL. NO DISCUSS AROUND HOW TO
GET Q. BACK THOUGH WE HIT
YELLOW FOR. SO I THINK WE ARE
NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT'S
MISTAKE WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
GIVING MONEY TO DISTRICTS. TO
ALLOW THEM THE CHOICE OF
WHETHER TO OPEN UP OR NOT. THE
MONEY IS TRUE IS FOR RE
OPENING- AS YOU ALL SEE THE ONE
THING WE'VE ALL AGREED ON IS WE
WANT SCHOOLS TO RE OPEN UP
THERE'S BEEN NO DISAGREEMENT.
AROUND THAT IN THIS BODY TODAY
REALLY IS ABOUT HOW WE DO IT
AND HOW WE SUPPORT SCHOOLS IN
DOING IT- BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE GET SCHOOLS OPEN
UP AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY LETTING DISTRICTS
DO IT ON THEIR OWN IN THEIR OWN
TIME FRAME HAS NOT WORKED. IT
HASN'T WORKED IN THE MOST
SMALLER DISTRICTS IT HASN'T
WORKED IN OUR LARGEST
DISTRICTS. SO WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE- MORE
CENTRALIZED GUIDANCE WE DO
APPRECIATE. THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THEIR
GUIDELINES IN TERMS OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES A SAFE RE OPENING
THE FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE. I THINK IT IS TIME
FOR. THE LEGISLATURE OR
GOVERNOR TO COME UP WITH OUR
OWN GUIDANCE IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE BELIEVE THE DISTRICTS-
SHOULD BE DOING. IN ORDER TO
SPEED THIS PROCESS OF RE
OPENING ALONG. SO WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE ALL MY COLLEAGUES
FOR COMMENTS THEIR FEEDBACK- WE
EAGERLY WILL CONTINUE THIS.
DISCUSSION. IN AGAIN- YOU KNOW
I. WANTED RE ITERATE HOW AND-
HAPPY ARE PROUD OF THE WORK WE
HAVE DONE IN TERMS OF THIS.
STIMULUS PURPLE. HAS SOME OF
YOU MAY RECALL THE LEGISLATURE
UNVEILED A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMIC STIMULUS
PROPOSAL. MANY OF THOSE IDEAS
IN TERMS OF A SMALL BUSINESS
GRANTS. MONEY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT. SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE FEE REDUCTION ARE
CONTAINED IN THIS ALMOST. OVER
NINE BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL WE
ARE VERY PROUD OF THAT AND
HOPING THAT- CALIFORNIANS SEE
THAT WE ARE DOING OUR BEST TO
TRY TO HELP THEM OUT IN THEIR
TIME OF NEED IT WITH THAT- WE
WILL ADJOURN THANK YOU.
SO THIS IS A CONTINUATION
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE WE APOLOGIZE WE
FORGOT TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT SO
WE ARE BRINGING BACK. WE'RE
BACK FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957. AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. AND SO IF
FIVE PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO CALL
IN AGAIN WE APOLOGIZE FOR
HANGING UP. 877-692-8957 AND
THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
SINCE IT'S NOT ON THE SCREEN I
WILL KEEP. REPEATING IT SINCE
IT'S NOT ON THE SCREEN. OH
SORRY OKAY WE WILL HOLD ON ONE
SECOND WE ARE GONNA BE USING A
DIFFERENT PHONE NUMBER BECAUSE
WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT. ROOM SO
HOLD ON ONE SECOND. THANK YOU
WE GET THAT POSTED CAN WE GET
THAT POSTED ON THE SCREEN AS
WELL.
OKAY SO THE PHONE NUMBERS
CORRECT EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
THE ACCESS CODE IS.
1-315-254-2021. THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO OH TWO. AGAIN THE
PHONE NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. OUR OKAY SO YOU'LL
SEE THE CODE IN THE ACCESS
NUMBER WE ARE HERE WE'RE GOING
TO SIT HERE FOR A LITTLE WHILE
WAITING FOR YOUR PHONE CALLS WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE OPERATOR- SEE
SEEING THE- T. V. S. PREVIOUS-
PEOPLE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS SO
IF ANYBODY STARTS CHIMING ON
ANOTHER THAT OPERATE ARE YOU
THERE. YES I AM HERE OKAY
OPERATE JUST LET US KNOW IF
ANYBODY STARTS CALLING IT IF
YOU COULD. OKAY WELL DO I- I
JUST OPEN THE ROOM- SO WE ARE
WE ARE READY- IF THEY IF THEY
DIAL IN PERFECT WE'LL JUST
WE'LL JUST WAIT HERE FOR A LOOK
AT THAT. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU.
THINK AGAIN APOLOGIZE WE
HAVE TO SWITCH ROOMS TO
CONTINUE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
BECAUSE WE NEED TO CLEAN THE
ROOM TO GET READY FOR THE
SESSION ON THE AGAIN THE PUBLIC
TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. IN THE CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OO
TO. AND WILL CONTINUE TO WAIT
FOR A LITTLE BIT LONGER TO SEE
A FARM FOLKS POPPED BACK ON WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE-
INCONVENIENCE AND THAT
MISCOMMUNICATION THANK YOU.
HELLO THIS IS THE OPERATOR
AGAIN WE HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE-
QUEUING UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE JUST LET ME KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE READY. YOU WE ARE READY
GO AHEAD PLEASE. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PLEASE START THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR KRISTEN YEP KRISTEN BROWN
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS- JUST WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR- YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING
THE FRUSTRATION HERE AND THE
NEED FOR CALEDONIAN THESE
BONDS. HI THERE ARE MANY
ASPECTS OF THIS- EIGHTY SIX
THAT GAVE A SIGH OF RELIEF FOR
OUR MEMBERS ESPECIALLY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- EDUCATORS
WOULD BE. PUT IN PRIORITY WHEN
IT CAME TO VACCINATION WE KNOW
THAT IS A HUGELY EFFICACIOUS
WAY T PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE- BUT ALSO- THE
MITIGATION FACTORS THAT ARE
OFTEN CITED ARE GREAT ON PAPER
BUT MAY FALL SHORT IN THE REAL
WORLD SO REAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
ON HOW BE RETURNED IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED- WE HAVE MANY MEMBERS
THAT HAVE BECOME ILL BECAUSE
OF. LAX STANDARDS AND SO THAT'S
A HUGE COMPONENT OF THIS INTO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY ON THESE
FUNDS WE AGREE WITH YOU IT'S
KEY AND ALSO JUST WANT TO
THANK. MEMBERS MCCARTY AND
O'DONNELL FOR THEIR COMMENTS
TODAY THEY RANG VERY TRUE FOR
US SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ON GOING OUT FOR IT. AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN RETURN IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION- AS. SAFE AND SANE
AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT. AND OUR NEXT PUBLIC
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU JESICA KAKO ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW HOW WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS THAT'S BEEN EVIDENT
BIKE TODAY CONVERSATION IT IS
ONE OF THE TOP PRIORITY. OF
CALIFORNIANS IN ADDITION WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
PROPOSAL TO INCLUDE ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE THE PRIORITY FOR
BEING SERVED IN EVERY OPENING
STRATEGIES WHICH HAS BEEN
CRITICAL WHICH IS CRITICAL
GIVEN THE UNIQUE AND
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES THAT-
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS HAVE
FACED- DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SPEED IS OF THE ESSENCE AND
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
OVERALL PROPOSED REOPENING PLAN
COULD IN FACT DELAY FROM AFTER.
THE APRIL FIFTEEN START DATE IS
WEEKS LATER THAN IT NEEDS TO BE
GIVEN THE URGENCY WITH WHICH
STUDENTS NEED TO BE PHYSICALLY
CONNECTED WITH THEIR SCHOOLS
AND TEACHERS. ARE THEREFORE AT
A MINIMUM WE BELIEVE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD REQUIRE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WITH SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS INCLUDING PP HAND
WASHING. SOCIAL DISTANCING IN
PLACE WHERE CASES ARE FEWER
THAN TWENTY FIVE PER HUNDRED
THOUSAND PERSON. IN ADDITION
THE DISTRIBUTION OF REOPENING
AND EXTENDED LEARNING FUND
SHOULD BE MORE EQUITABLE
SPECIFICALLY THEIR ALLOCATION
SHOULD BE ON THE BASIS OF AN
ALLEY A PROPORTION OF
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
FUND STATEWIDE. AND FINALLY. WE
ARE CURRENTLY POLICYMAKERS TO
UTILIZE EXPANDED LEARNING STAFF
FOR ONE ON ONE TUTORING AND NOT
LIMITED TO CLASSIFIED AND
CREDENTIAL STAFF AS WE
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT EXPANDED LEARNING PROGRAMS
WHICH ARE NOT ALWAYS EMPLOYERS
TO CLASSIFY CHAPTER- ARE IN
PUBLIC PARTNERS JELLY EIGHT.
THANK YOUNG I COULD NOT COMMENT.
THANK YOU. NOT SPEAKER. IN OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM A LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN MEMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE'RE CALLING
JUST TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT-
FOR THE PASSAGE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES DIDN'T- SB EIGHTY
SEVEN AND SB EIGHTY EIGHT THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK- DOING
THIS- BETWEEN THE PASSAGE OF
THESE BILLS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. AND OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI KATIE HARTMAN AT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PRIORITIZING
SAFETY EVERY OPENING SCHOOL FOR
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION EPA
SUPPORT MANY ASPECTS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN PLAN INCLUDING
PRIORITIZING BACK BEING FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. NOT
INCENTIVIZING LARGE SCALE
REOPENING IN THE PURPLE TEAR
REINFORCING THE CDPH AND HELLO
SIR THANK YOU SANDERS INCLUDING
TESTING AND PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES FOR OUR SCHOOLS BOTH
FOR RE OPENING AND ECONOMIC
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORT WE
BELIEVE ALL THESE THINGS ARE
ESSENTIAL AND RE OPENING OUR
SCHOOLS IN THE STATE THAT PLAY
POSSIBLE. WE DO HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED WITH USING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR HEALTH READ IT
RELATED COSTS SUCH AS AT THE
ENTRY THEME AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BACK FILL THESE
OF NONPROFIT ANY FUNDING. WE'RE
GOING TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU ALSO WHICH IS
SAVE ANYBODY IN PERSON ONE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE STEP UP
TO THE MICROPHONE. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. AND OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTEEN AM I AM COMMITTEE. YOU
ARE WE CAN HEAR YOU. YOU
CHANGED ROOMS YOU CHANGE
NUMBERS AND YOU KICKED A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS OFF THE CALL BUT
I'M BACK I FOUND YOU THE FIVE
ZERO NASDAQ PFPT AND MODERNO
NASDAQ GS MRNA VACCINES ARE
BOTH MRNA TREATMENTS. BOTH
COMPANIES ARE TRADED ON WALL
STREET WITH HEDGE FUNDS BEING
THE MAIN SHAREHOLDER HOLDERS
THEY FUNCTION BY REPROGRAMMING
THE RECIPIENT CELL AT THE
CYTOPLASM LEVEL NOT ONLY ARE
THE CODE BAXEEN UNPROVEN THE
TREATMENT ITSELF M. RNA IS ONLY
A FEW YEARS OLD. THE ENTIRE
HUMAN POPULATION INCLUDING
TEACHERS AND POTENTIALLY
STUDENT IS BEING ASKED BY THE
MEDIA BY THE WALL STREET MEDIA
FEEDBACK LOOP TO BE GENETICALLY
REPROGRAMMED BY A BRAND NEW
EXPERIMENTAL TREATMENT OF
QUESTIONABLE EFFICACY THAT
CAUSES SERIOUS SIDE EFFECTS
INCLUDING DEATH. ALSO DISEASE
THAT HAS A NINETY NINE POINT 9%
SURVIVAL RATE AND OPPOSES
ALMOST AT NO RISK TO CHILDREN
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY GO WRONG
WHAT WOULD GO WRONG I'M
REMINDED OF A PROVERB THE
WICKED FLEE WHEN NONE PURSUE
IT. AS I SAT HERE FOR THREE
HOURS LISTENING TO YOUR
LEGISLATORS ARGUE LIKE TODDLERS
FIGHTING OVER TOYS IN A SAND
PILE WELL CALIFORNIA DIED YOU
CALIFORNIANS OFF YOU DENY US
THE RIGHT TO GOVERNMENT YOU
DON'T WANT US TO SPEAK OUR
MINDS YOU YOU YOU WERE ROLLED
CALIFORNIA WITH AN IRON FIST.
AND THE PEOPLE ARE DONE AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE POINT IS THAT WE
HAVE A VERY GOOD STEADY WE CALL
EFFORTS UNDER WAY. AND YOU
CAN'T GET ALONG WITH THE
GOVERNOR YOU CAN'T GET ALONG
WITH YOUR STYLES AND WE'RE
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAYS
PLUS INTO OUR STUDENTS 80% OF
THEM ARE NOT BY YOUR- THANK YOU.
AND AGAIN PUBLICLY IS FOR THE
AGENDA I THE YOU. IN OUR NEXT
COME COMES FROM THE LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ROBERTA
RODRIGUEZ SOME A TEACHER IN THE
SWEETWATER UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AS WELL AS THE TRUSTEE FOR THE
PALOMAR COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND-
ONE NO ONE WANTS TO RETURN IN
PERSON TO IN PERSON INSTRUCTION
MORE THAN TEACHERS- WE WANT TO
DO IT SAFELY. SO I WANT TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
APPLE APPROACH THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TO ENSURING SAFETY
INCLUDING A MULTI LAYERED
APPROACH A REASONABLE TIMELINE
PER SE WE RETURNING. TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS
PROVIDING FUNDING TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE
MOST CHALLENGED UNDER DISTANCE
EDUCATION- I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MINUTE AND EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. IN OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM THE LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHAYCE
SUPPRESSANT WITH THE COMPANY
SCHOOL CLOYD BECAUSE CREATION.
REPRESENT TO ONE IN FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND WE WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR GREAT COMMENTS
TODAY PEOPLE WANT TO OPEN
SCHOOLS BUT WE WANT TO DO
BASICALLY. ON SB EIGHTY SIX WE
WOULD ASK THAT. YOU CONTINUE TO
PRESS TO GET PARA PROFESSIONALS
INTO THE CLASSROOM TO HELP OUT
TEACHERS THERE'S SO MUCH OUT
THERE AND THEY'RE NOT TO STUDY
THE TALK ABOUT HOW PARA
PROFESSIONALS CAN MAKE A GREAT
DIFFERENCE TO DO THE ONE ON ONE
INDIVIDUALIZED. LEARNING
DESIGNATED HE ALSO WOULD URGE
YOU TO LOOK AT THE VACCINE
ISSUE THAT WE LIKE WHAT'S IN
THE BILL WE WOULD ALSO URGE YOU
TO CONSIDER OUR STRUGGLES AND
OTHER QUOTES YOU MAY NOT BE
TIED TO A PARTICULAR SCHOOL
SITE. BUT WILL NEED TO HAVE THE
VACCINE BECAUSE THEY WILL ALSO
INTERACT WHICH IT'S NOT
EVERYBODY THAT TRACKING AT ONE
SCHOOL SITE. ON ON THOSE TWO
ISSUES YOU WANT TO THANK YOU
THANK YOU. TO CHAIR MCCARTY AND
THE STILL DOMINANT POLITICALLY
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER PLEASE. AND OUR NEXT
COME COMES FROM THE LINE FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME THE
AND BURKE AND AM A TEACHER FROM
THE RAMON VALLEY- YOU SCHOOL
DISTRICT I ALSO IN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION THAT I'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO TODAY. I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT SAN RAMON IS
ONE OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT DID NEGOTIATE KERR THE
GUIDANCE THAT CAME OUT ON
JANUARY FOURTEENTH GOING BACK
TO SCHOOL AND WE ARE FACING AND
WEBER OUR YOUNGEST CHILDREN
STARTING AND WE GET TO THE RED
CARE WILL BE ENTERING INTO THE-
SECOND PHASE I WANT YOU KNOW
THAT IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT. TO
CONDUCT THE OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES AND ENSURE COMPLIANCE
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
WITNESSING IT AT ALL LEVELS AND
SO ONE WAY THAT WE CAN KEEP
EVERYBODY SAFE AND OUR GOAL IS
GETTING THE VACCINATION THAT.
REALLY HARD TO GET THE
APPOINTMENTS I HAVE MEMBERS ARE
TRYING TO DO AND GET ONLINE AND
TO GET THOSE APPOINTMENTS AND
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH FOR THE
VACCINATION AND THAT THEY SAID
WE ARE BACK AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE- HAVE THAT
COMMUNITY IN COMPLIANCE AND
THAT WE CONTINUE TO. ADHERE TO
ALL OF THE MEDICARE THE LAYERS
WHICH WE WERE ABLE TO NEGOTIATE
AND- SO FAR WE HAVE AT HAS BEEN
THAT IT'S BEEN CONDUCTED DURING
THE SURVEILLANCE AND WE ARE
FINDING THAT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
ARE COMING DOWN WITH.
POSITIVITY CASES SO ALL OF
THESE LAYERS ARE SUPER
IMPORTANT TO THE SAFETY AND
WELL. BEING OF OUR COMMUNITY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN OUR
NEXT COMMENT FROM A LINE WHEN
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND HAPPY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES A MEMBER OF THE
EQUITY COALITION COMMITTEE SB
EIGHTY THANK WE APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS THE PROPOSED REOPENING
PLAN DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH
FAST ENOUGH APRIL FIFTEENTH RE
OPENING DATE AS WEEKS LATER
THAN IT NEEDS TO BE STUDENTS
URGENTLY NEED TO PHYSICALLY
RECONNECT WITH THEIR SCHOOLS
AND FUTURE AND RE OPENING WE
BELIEVE COMPLETELY HAPPEN AS
EARLY AS NEXT MONTH. THE
LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL IN NORTH
MILLIONS OF ELEMENTARY STUDENTS
AT PURPLE COUNTY WHERE MOST OF
THE STATE DIDN'T PROVIDE MANY
OF THE STUDENTS ARE LOW INCOME
BLACK AND BROWN STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT FALL WITHIN THE HIGH NEED
CATEGORIES IDENTIFIED BUT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM A RETURNED
IN PERSON INSTRUCTION. COREY
OPENING SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
AS MANY STUDENTS AS POSSIBLE
BASED ON THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE INCLUDING MANDATING RE
OPENING FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
AND PROPOSED HERE AT A MINIMUM
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD ADOPT
THE GOVERNOR'S MORE MODEST
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD REQUIRE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION FOR
ELEMENTARY STUDENTS AND PURPLE
COUNTY IS. WORKING THROUGH
THEIR FEWER THAN TWENTY FIVE
PER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ADDITIONALLY THE DISTRIBUTION
OF RE OPENING AN EXTENDED
LEARNING FUND SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED MORE EQUITABLY BASED
ON PROPORTIONAL SUPPLEMENTAL
AND CONCENTRATION FUND RATHER
THAN USING THE PHARMACY AT THAT
FORMULA. HE DID OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS THE HIGH NEED STUDENTS
GROUPS AND ALL. SEVEN BE
PROVIDED THE OPTION OF A PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WE LIMITED. RATE
COMMENTS YOUR CONCERT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE
ENTER IN OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
MEMBERS SURELY DOWN BEHALF TO
CALGARY PRESENTATION WE WANT TO
BE A MUCH RICHER FOR ITS WORK
TODAY ON SCHOOL RE OPENING AND
WE BELIEVE SB SIX PACK HELPED
MOVE THE NEEDLE HOWEVER THERE
ARE STILL SOME ISSUES THAT NEED
ADDITIONAL TIME TO ADDRESS TO
ENSURE IMPLEMENTATION AND WE
REGRET THAT NO READER MEYER
HERE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING. THE CONVERSATION
WITH YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE SPEAKER PLEASE. AND WE HAVE
BEEN NO FURTHER PEOPLE WISHING
TO COMMENT. OKAY WE WON'T WAIT
MAYBE ONE MORE MINUTE- TO SEE
IF ANYBODY ELSE THE PEERS ARE
JUMPED ON THE LINE AND THEN
OTHERWISE WE WILL. THE GERMAN
SO OPERATOR MAYBE GIVE IT ONE
MORE MINUTE AND SEE IF ANYBODY
ELSE JUMPS ON. THEN AGAIN WELL
DAVID THANK YOU. AND AGAIN THE
PHONE NUMBERS ON ONLINE CORRECT
SO PEOPLE CAN SEE IT. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S SOME FLEXIBILITY
AND JUMPING ONTO A NEW PHONE
NUMBER WITH THE NEW CODE FOR
THE PROJECT THAT. AN OPERATOR
JUST OFFER A LITTLE BIT OF
HOUSEKEEPING YOU HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING I THINK PROBABLY WILL
TAKE PLACE IN ABOUT ANOTHER.
OUR OUR SO. WITH THE SAME CODE.
THANK THANK YOU PERFECT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE BILL WILL BE
IN THE SAME ROOM AS WELL.
OKAY
OPERATOR ANY ANY OTHER COLORS
COME IN. WE STILL HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY. VERY
GOOD THEN I BELIEVE THEN WE
WILL ADJOURN ARE HEARING WILL
ADJOURN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE HEARING THANK YOU SO
MUCH.